30 seconds did you ever think you were
made
Sweet Victory I know this life meant for
me yeah why would you bet on Goliath
when we got bad David now you came and
giving values contagious
homie look what I become
yeah yo so today my day started off with
doing this blue cube cold Plunge in the
morning let me tell you I'm wide awake I
first went in I got a video of it I'll
post it later on it's embarrassed some
of it I'm probably having a post
embarrassing part as well you have to
first I went in uh with my feet I said
there's no way then I went in for like a
few seconds jumped out then I went in
for 45 seconds and the last one was a
minute or two and then when I get home
today I'm gonna try to do it for two
minutes but it felt unfreaking
believable shout out to the guys at blue
cube I'll post it you'll see what it is
I'm on fire I have a question for you so
you're usually awake in the morning
so what's the difference between this
icy pbd just think about like putting an
ice pack on your back after a workout
yeah but imagine putting an ice pack on
your entire body you're in the ice for a
minute it felt now what happened no bad
because now and you're drinking ice
water which is like now
we have great topics to discuss I know
you uh were hardcore into Tucker's
recent show he did with the gentleman
yeah Larry Sinclair who claims he uh
smoked crack and they had uh gay sex
whatever years ago that's what his claim
is obviously you may do the
investigation I did something people
have lost their minds one on that side
on the left on the right and the middle
and there's a group of people that could
care less about it but we'll kind of
touch it a little bit we'll touch it a
little bit
at all but we got some economy stuff to
talk about Spotify something crazy
happened with Spotify Tom something uh
funny happened with Spotify Spotify
spent a in a billion dollars into
podcasts of famous people Obamas
Kardashians and uh what do you call it a
princess
Prince Harry and Mary whatever
and they canceled all of them they
canceled all of it and you'll find out
how much money they lost and what their
thoughts are on this how many billions
did you you spend on this podcast we
didn't spend billions but this is a
billion dollar party
Saudi Arabia man sentenced to death for
tweets we'll talk about that the U.S
government folks be careful what you're
wearing right now the U.S government is
investing 22 million dollars into
developing surveillance clothing that
includes shirts pants and underwear they
want to see everything right uh elamas
dad said he's worried that Tesla CEO may
be assassinated following a report about
his influence on government decisions
we'll see about that and then we got
half of the CDC workers ready for this
more than half of CDC staff leave to
work for big Pharma study finds anyone
surprised I'm shocked in China
in China there's a county that offers
couples to get married before the age of
25. they want you making babies that's
what they want you to do in China
uh small towns in America are disbanding
police forces the Immortals meet the
billionaires forking out for eternal
life wait wait till you hear this story
and then a New York Times story this is
not a New York Post story this is a New
York Times story which we're probably
going to get to first Americans are
losing faith in the value of college
whose fault is that then we got a bunch
of other stories what happened with
proud boys going 22 years uh but Liberty
Safe if you own a safe in your house
this is definitely not a sponsorship
Liberty Safe could possibly be the next
Bud Light when you find out what these
guys did with FBI maybe one of the
biggest maybe bigger than Bud Light it
has to be bigger than Bud Light screw up
on what you're doing your whole idea is
about making sure we feel safe and
you're giving that to the FBI what and
then last night some story came out with
Reuters will cover uh Apple stock is
down four percent if you haven't already
looked our guys in the back were not too
happy about the fact when I announced
this China
is making an announcement to no longer
wanting to use uh the iPhone uh they
have just imposed an immediate ban on on
all Apple devices by government
officials I don't know if this is
because Tim Cook is taking the business
out to India or not but we'll cover that
as well Congress returns with clock tick
in to avert government shutdown fund U.S
disaster then Messi drives jump in Apple
TV and MLS subscription another bad news
for cable TV and we've got a few other
stories and maybe we'll get get into as
well anyways but before we do uh do that
we have a friend here with us the latest
Talent we signed comedian the phenomenal
Kavon if you haven't seen the stuff I've
watched the stuff over the years funny
as hell we started talking I want to say
two years ago was the first time we
communicated 2018 I looked it up
five years I've been on I've been on
Pat's case for a while five years to do
this man and I said dude what do we got
to do about this and uh so now he's here
with us in South Florida Kayvon if you
don't mind take 30 seconds to a minute
just kind of give everybody your
background well absolutely really I have
been doing stand-up comedy for the last
12 15 years I know Vinnie very well and
when he moved out here I said man you
beat me to it I was trying to get here
first Vinnie's always first to Market
with this stuff but uh I'm the most
famous half Persian comedian in the
world
luckily there's only one other one so as
long as uh I stay here I'll be okay and
uh I just love making people laugh I
linked up with Turning Point USA at one
point and we believe in freedom of
speech and doing stand-up comedy and pbd
believes in these values as well so this
is just a great partnership I think it's
gonna go real far awesome well it's good
to have you here Kayvon uh let's get
into our first story okay Americans are
losing faith and the value of college
whose fault is that Mr Ellsworth let me
read this story okay Tom's fault a
decade ago survey showed strong support
for college with 86 percent of college
graduates seeing it as a good investment
but today only about a third of
Americans have a lot of confidence in
higher education and just about 41
percent of young adult view a college
degree as very important that's only 41
percent the rising cost of college has
played a significant role in the shift
with tuition fees nearly doubling for
for your private college since 1992
total student that has surged from 500
billion dollars uh to uh in 2007 to 1.6
trillion dollars that's just in 16 years
it's tripled leading to financial
burdens and hindering wealth
accumulation for many graduates and by
the way you can't even follow bankruptcy
on your college that you have to pay you
don't have a choice the decline in faith
in higher education is also politically
driven as Republican sentiment has
sharply dropped in 2015 58 Republicans
believe colleges had a negative impact
in the country compared to 37 percent
and 25 so anyways we're going to see
what's going to happen here Tom your
thoughts on the story well there are
three angles of the story one is college
useful number two is it worth the price
and number three are there other things
happening like indoor Nation that
parents are upset about the first one
usefulness two studies I found said that
last year it dipped under 50 percent of
college graduates got a job related to
what they just studied and paid for so
only fifty percent so you know you have
parents that are so shocked at home wait
a minute you're telling me European art
history you've been able to find a job
in a European art history here in the
United States that's the whole point
liberal arts educations in the esoteric
majors are not useful so only half
people are finding jobs and what they
just studied then they look at the
return on investment I walk out with
student loans and I find a job
in what I just studied marketing
business but they look at the price and
how long it's going to take them to pay
for it minus whatever minor academic
scholarships or need-based scholarships
or whatever they got there's still a net
there it's like now I got to pay this
off and then the last one were parents
who are footing the bill for the people
I just mentioned if they don't get
student loans are saying wait a minute
you you know you remember the old thing
about the weather that March comes in
like a lamb goes out like a lion you
know there's a little joke about the
weather well parents are like my kid
goes in like a moderate and comes out
like a Marxist and it's like I don't I
don't like this yeah and so that's the
three things is it useful is it worth
the money and the indoctrination and
people have had it students have had it
parents have had it and then later on
when a student becomes an adult and
they're paying for it they've had so can
I challenge you so for you even though
you're saying that you're still
encouraging your kids to go to college
why is that uh okay let's rewind uh
number one I've saved my pennies I don't
think it's worth it but my kids are
going to come out with without
significant burdens so they don't have
to get held back once they start their
career but the second is you and I have
had a conversation about this I will
fund stem business or pre-med pre-law
again there's a whole list of things you
can do in life I'm willing to fund that
because I want to be at the top part of
the 50 that have a degree that's
actually usable and so but I'm I'm on
the fence if I was probably 10 years
older I might take a son or daughter and
put them in an apprenticeship with me
and really think twice on this because I
see where this is going in 10 years down
the road I don't know if that Tom
Ellsworth would make this decision I
agree with Tom that that's it's
multifaceted because it's not one size
fits all so on one hand you're also
almost saying like it's not worth it the
ROI isn't there but at the same time
you're encouraging your daughters to go
because why there's a plan for them the
biggest problem that I have with
colleges is most people
kids are 18 years old and they're about
to take make the biggest decision of
their life and they're just not equipped
to make that decision yeah they don't
have the money college debt is
ridiculous you know you know how long it
takes the average student debt recipient
to pay back their loans 20 years it
takes a long freaking time so at one on
one hand you know if you look at the
stats going backwards times have changed
internet technology Drop Shipping social
media everything entrepreneurship is now
a buzzword it used to be a new word
um high school students high school
graduates would make one million dollars
over their lifetime if you graduate high
school
college degrees would equivocate to two
million dollars NBA's three million
dollars but the times have changed it's
just not what it used to be and then
here's the last point
I actually think that most kids unless
you're you know an Ellsworth daughter
and you have a game plan and you're not
taking on debt you're not basically
driving up the price of uh everything in
the rest of your life I think that there
should be
I don't want to say a mandate but
encouragement for most kids to take a
gap year I think that there is a lack of
national pride I think there's a lack of
national servitude I think there's a a
lack of community service and I would
encourage most kids if you do not have a
game plan for your life go take one year
go to Americorps go do an internship go
give back to your country I like that
learn whether whether it's in health
care whether it's in Tech whether it's
in anything entrepreneurship and there's
only one
thing that you have to do if you're
going to do this every morning
every employee or every intern whatever
it is there's only one thing you have to
do the Pledge of Allegiance that's the
only thing and they will basically pay
for you and do whatever you need to do
and then you can take that year to
figure out the game plan for the rest of
your life's waving his hand but you also
in Israel You're compelled to have two
years of getting you have to go two
years of the army yeah you have to
that's gangster so bottom line is this
at 18 you don't need to make the biggest
decision for the rest of your life and
then just drown yourself in debt it's
okay to start college when you're 19.
it's okay to start college when you're
20. you don't have to make this decision
when you're 18. and for the parents out
there get the message for your kids well
let me just add one thing they sued
Trump University because people weren't
getting what they thought they were
going to get out of it no problem what
is the difference when colleges keep
hiking up their rates and then they just
go well Joe Biden will pay that off we
want student debt relief why can't we
have a class action lawsuit and say hey
you're providing these degrees they're
not going anywhere somebody owes it back
and I think it's the institutions and
not the taxpayer and that that's
actually a very a good point as well you
know for me I will tell you for you and
I uh going in the military was
life-changing I think if a if a boy
that's becoming a man doesn't yet have a
set of you know direction of what they
want to do with their lives and you're
not a uh uh what do you call it you're
not a person that's maybe got a 4.1 GPA
maybe you got like a 2.2 GPA military
may not be a bad option for you Pat it
made me excuse me my father you know I
mean he was there they were not divorced
they were he was announced but drank and
never really wasn't the father that I
needed right so the military discipline
you know being on time cleaning it makes
you like being that experience I'm not
only a patriot my my life my goal my
making my bed it regiments you to where
you're on point especially somebody I
had a father that didn't have you know I
mean didn't have somebody I'm sorry to
hear about your daddy issues I know a
lot of girls with those issues but I
know that you know I'm gonna cry after
okay I know you're gonna be okay but I
will say there is a difference between
what men and women do for working after
college do you have no idea how many
girls that I have on my show I've had
this conversation a million times they
go to college they graduate and what do
they do they become bartenders or they
become servers or they start doing only
fans some even start stripping and
they're like why why do you do this
because you make more money it's like
well then why did you spend all that
money on College and then Tom hit the
nail on the head unless you're unless
guys out there specifically are going
into stem stem stands for not stem cell
yeah STEM Science Tech engineering math
that's a male dominated career path so
men need to make that decision but I I
it's crazy to me that you go to college
you spend all this money you take on
debt and then only fans here we come for
the ladies yeah we don't have that
option but you're sending your kids to
college ideally no so are you saying
like I I take your message in a couple
different ways sure one of the ways I
take it I take it as in your Ideal World
there needs to be a way a course in
college to how to effectively improve
your own defense account
so what are you going to go to college
I'm not going to college why are you not
going to college
he says that you know what I'm going to
be doing oh wow I said let's just say it
doesn't work out Daddy what are you
going to be doing this is Dad I'm not
going I'm not going I don't need to go
to college look at you I'm like buddy
you got a 4.0 GPA all your grades are
straight A's you're like the best
student you know you get you're doing
great stuff with school with sports but
all this stuff I'm not going to go to
college yet I said Okay so let's just
play this what if you get a scholarship
from XYZ school to go play football or
baseball or whatever with them right or
soccer with them what are you going to
do you're not going to go no because I'm
going straight to play for Barcelona
straight that's his mindset he's so
flipping competitive but Chico knows
from right here hey you know that I'm
going to go to USC or I would like to go
to a school that's not to woke his words
yeah I would like to go to a school
where I can learn how to become a movie
guy Steven Spielberg all this stuff but
he talks a different language than Dylan
and in our household we can entertain
both thoughts okay let's go to the next
topic here Spotify a billion dollar
podcast bet turns into a Serial dilemma
this is a Wall Street Journal story so
they invested the page 20. they invested
a billion dollars in podcasts and
including high profile deals with
figures like Kim Kardashian Obama's
Prince Harry and Meghan Markle has not
resulted in profitability for most of
his shows the company lost
565 million dollars in its in the first
half of 2023 despite generating 6.2
billion dollars in Revenue while the U.S
podcast and Industry is growing with
expected revenue of 2.3 billion dollars
in 2023 Spotify substantial invest in
the medium haven't translated into
profitability the company faced
increase competition and exclusive
podcast didn't significantly draw new
subscribers away from Rivals to meet its
profitability goal by 2024 Spotify has
taken measures such as laying off 200
employees raising subscription prices
and sharing Revenue risk with Talent
this is one thing I will tell you just
because you're famous just because
you're famous in one area doesn't mean
your podcast is going to be great just
because you were the greatest in another
space you may be very boring and you
don't know how to Value tame people
Obama and you know Bruce Springsteen's
podcast after you're being canceled it
was boring people are like what am I
gonna by the way most people didn't even
know Kardashian had a I still don't spot
a podcast on Spotify
Prince Harry and Meghan Markle think
about it now here's the thing Kardashian
can do Kim can do a uh uh keeping up
with Kardashians in 20 plus years and be
successful that's that's a very
different world that somebody is telling
you what to do you're coming up with
drama there's fights there's punching
there's cat fights there's breakups
there's divorces there's all this stuff
Obama you could be a president you get
up you got a nice teleprompter you give
a nice motivational speech you can go
out there and be a Megan Merkel and
Prince Harry and be entitled and be
annoying and be arrogant and be blaming
your family destroying a legacy and just
everything that no one with the right
character would support one to do and
get all these eyeballs 100 million out
on Netflix uh you know uh opportunity
where now they want money back they're
not even paying you the rest but to to
to be able to carry a podcast like Rogan
has every penny they invested into him
they've made back and more there's a few
people that know how to play this game
this isn't for everybody and fame alone
is not enough can I tell you what Meghan
Markle was doing what uh your podcasts
are intriguing because you care about
the person you're interviewing yeah she
was having a sit-in interview the person
and then she would then go redub the
questions on her camera so she was never
there in front of the purse and she was
talking get out of here that is exactly
what she was doing I wonder why it
failed well look
um you think pretty well for all the
people out there we're talking about
famous people let me talk to the people
that are trying to think about starting
their own podcast or starting their own
podcast you think this is easy I think
you just get some microphones and start
talking and voila you have a million
subscribers breaking news if it was easy
everyone would do it speaking of
everyone would do it I believe that
podcasting is the new.com of the 2000s
or cryptos of the 2010s or nfts of two
years ago and now everyone's jumping on
board what's the what's the um the story
back in the day when it comes to
investing it's like uh buy the rumors
sell the news podcasts are on the news
buddy time to sell and you have no idea
how many people I speak to like I'm
thinking about starting a podcast and I
do everything I can to talk them out of
it I'm like oh yeah what are you gonna
do when you're doing it for a year and
you have uh 12 subscribers right or you
spend four hours doing a video and you
get a hundred views at what point you're
gonna be like dude this ain't worth it
it ain't worth it out there for most
people uh you talked about famous people
I will say something there just to
challenge you a little bit on that so it
depends on what the outcome is meaning
I think everybody should consider
starting a podcast okay but what's the
outcome for example watch what I'm
saying here to you guy calls me says hey
Pat if you give us a million dollars per
year we'll bring we'll do a podcast with
you I'm like okay you ever done that
before no but I have a lot of Juicy
stories okay how many one two no I got
50. okay but what are you doing it for
is it just for money I think we can get
a lot of money we're seeing what's going
on with podcasting that's a risk I had a
call with a guy yesterday a minute 15
minute with a guy yesterday uh uh you
know asking me questions so he goes to
manec.com and on there you get 450
minutes bunch of people are asking
questions about dating all this stuff
you get my next people want to ask you
about comedy all these things they do
minute with you all the time on business
advice raising money and if Rob if you
can put the link below to Minute To Go
download the app it's available on
Google and apple and all over the place
anyways
so he asked me a question he says hey
Pat you know what I want to do is I got
this uh podcast and I've been doing you
know Plumbing for this many years and
you know we're blowing up and the
plumbing business and the construction
business we're selling companies for 200
million dollars we're doing successful
super successful guy but I'm willing to
bring my podcast to you
so I'm like really what's the name of
your podcast I go online 29 views great
32 degrees man for a million dollars for
a million no but the way he said it like
I'm willing to bring the podcast to you
yeah like you should be lucky that's the
wrong approach why is that the wrong
approach your first thing you got to do
do it because you want to do it number
two don't do it because you want to make
money because it's very hard if you do
it just because you want to make money
it's going to take a lot of years for
you to make money with it but do it
because you want to do it even if it's
once a month you start with once a week
you do something like that then once you
have a proof of concept that you're
winning out there then we'll find you
like when Vinnie first reached out to me
I'm like remember one time I was sitting
there showing you Vinnie videos
yeah I'm showing Vinnie videos I'm like
this freaking guy is so funny it wasn't
baseball it was yeah so we're gonna go
out there to Vinnie the Luchi so hey
what's going on out there and I was like
who is this the mafia stuff right Kayvon
I watch kayvon's videos on the skits
he's doing and you know I come back from
Harvard I'm like Tom you got to start
doing a show for case study we didn't do
it because Tom's going to make money I
talked to him like dude you got to get
on camera I don't know what you're going
to be doing but you got to do something
you didn't want to do any of this stuff
2016. that was in 2016. yeah but that's
the right way to get into it because
there's a love of the game if you got
love with the game you're gonna some
people and by the way online they're
freaking brutal they'll tell you what an
idiot oh he's so full of him so oh look
at you he thinks he's funny look how
ugly he is look at his this look at it
they're not gonna hold back of making
fun of you so for me I say do it if
you're doing it for the right reasons
don't do it if you want to get rich I
will say this just to kind of
counterbalance what you're saying uh
well number one nobody makes mean
comments online everyone's a nice one
especially to you oh I'm pretty sure
right thank you guys
you know you talk about all right you
want to get a podcast you want to tell
your story yeah you know who cares about
your story guy who wants to start a
podcast nobody yeah nobody gives a
nobody cares about you nobody wants to
hear your story unless you're providing
value to them if you're doing it because
you actually want to make a difference
because you actually want to give back
because you have empathy and Authority
that's a big difference I didn't start
podcasting until I made my money and I
was like yeah I'll do this and I'm not
doing this for money I'm doing this
because I made my money and now there's
something more that I want to do with my
life and give back so if you're doing
this because you think you want to start
a career uh you're doing it the other
way around make your money have some
Authority do something in business do
something in Life Council have a comedic
background how make a name for yourself
and then start podcast Tom you know
there's actually a story behind the
story here on Spotify and for those of
you that have a business they actually
did two things I think were correct but
they made mistakes along the way first
thing is they go public in 2018 largely
in music play but they had real good
success with a premium I paid for
Spotify Premium I thought it gave me
more than Apple and Pandora and a good
variety and everything and after they
went public they decided you know what
music is a red ocean and any time Apple
could move the price per song down to 52
cents so we want to we want to
strategically do something look podcasts
are coming let's own it Rob which stock
is this I can't tell you because Spotify
stocks and go to Max on that we'll get
to that in a second
um if you would please so they take
their money and they go out and they
they overpay they pay 235 for megaphone
140 for anchors so that they bought
these services so they could serve and
launch and Syndicate podcasts and then
they did one thing right on Talent one
thing wrong you never never never never
overpay on exclusivity for an unproven
Talent never so when they went out and
got Rogan smart he already had a
subscribers he was already blown up on
YouTube he was what's called a free
agent and they were What's called the
Yankees and you can make the check same
thing for Bill Simmons you don't have to
like Bill Simmons he's a little liberal
but he had the ringer they went out and
bought him later 2021 they went out and
about call her her daddy out of free
agency off of Barstool but then they do
these things thinking that you know Kim
you know Megan and Harry and Obama
completely unproven and you throw money
at them for exclusivity exclusive what
yeah exclusive what you're getting
exclusive what you're getting exclusive
rookie that's not the way to do it and
so now they've come back and said it
didn't work we're redoing the contracts
we're cutting programming and if you go
take a look there over the last month
and a half the stock market what did I
say about layoffs the market loves
layoffs when they're truthful and it
turns it into ebitda and take a look
they're bouncing back up however the
interesting thing here Spotify since
they've gone out in 2018 they are eight
percent more valuable than when they
went out and Pat take a look at this
they go up in the top of 2021 that was
music and then they came down when they
were suffering red ink losses because of
all the stuff they done podcast you see
that and now they say you know what
we're going to get out of the pot
when was it when they were trying to
cancel Rogan can you pull up the dates
on when they try to cancel Rogue 21-22
okay so so I'm curious too 2020 was the
buying spree on all this Talent no no I
get the buying experience but when was
it when they were trying to cancel them
so that's February 2022 when did people
say we're gonna remove our music and all
that stuff is that around that time it
was about a year ago okay go back to the
stock
yeah I would go back to the stock so 20
so if you go 20 February no it was
already going down so that's good that's
got nothing can I comment on this graph
right here I think this graph is sort of
synonymous with any tech savvy company
during covet everyone's isolated social
distancing they're on their phones
they're in their homes everything blows
up I mean Zoom stock I think would be
look exactly like this if not even worse
compare higher it's a higher Peak
exactly but so it's just you talk about
fake success a lot of fake success
happened during coven because the world
completely changed all the tech stuff
anything that allowed you to do anything
um work from anywhere everything was was
great everything was up uh look is this
Zoom right here yeah that's exactly
what's going on so you your point is I'm
just saying that's coming with
everything so stop by dropped because of
Spotify they dropped because it was all
Tech reversion to the mean right
everything's going back to where it
should be 600 million loss differences
the difference is which good point the
difference is
Zoom went down they stayed down Spotify
is coming back up because they're making
better strategies and better Investments
they got a bump Zoom has not had a bump
yet so we'll see what happens Zoom is
like the equivalent of having a huge
massive one-hit song called covet love
and then boom they never had a hit again
okay all right let's go to the next
story which kind of goes coincides with
this messy drives jump in Apple TV plus
and MLS subscription another Wall Street
Journal story Lionel Messi's arrival in
North America has a profound impact on
subscriptions with over 110 000 new US
signups for MLS season pass on the day
of his intern you know Miami debut a
leap of the prior days 6143 so they went
from
6143 people signing up to a hundred and
ten thousand people one day signing up
in one day by the way that's nearly 20 x
okay Apple TV's experience substantial
growth and subscription in July making
the strongest month for new customers in
2023 driven by Messi's presence Apple
CEO Tim Cook acknowledged the positive
influence of Messi's moved to Inner
Miami under subscriber numbers Apple's
2.5 billion dollar deal would MLS
granting exclusive streaming rights
globally has proven successful even with
a smaller subscriber base compared to
Rivals like Netflix Tom well here you go
uh Messi was a proven proven commodity
comes over to the U.S market Apple TV
says we're going to foreground this
we're going to make the MLS season pass
and that's gonna and by the way
tell me if you've heard this story
before Apple TV wants to drive uh
subscriptions to Apple TV so it creates
an exclusive relationship with the sport
now what do we know about sport every
year you want to watch it's not like I
got I got tired of that series it kind
of got burnt out of me you know Game of
Thrones finally burned out there's
nothing new no sport is your team every
year there's a new opportunity a new
dream a new champion and you have that
it's the same thing DirecTV did with
Sunday Ticket remember DirecTV was the
only place you could get all the NFL
games and they they owned that market
Apple's done the same thing here it's
incredibly smart and Messi was
incredibly smart in this contract to say
Hey you know this thing called upside
yeah I want a piece of that you know you
know it's crazy there's three things
that's keeping Cable in business one is
old people two is Big Pharma and three
is sports watch this old people you got
a decade or two with them if you're
lucky sports they're about to be picked
up by all these other streaming
companies that are you know picking them
up three big cable previous one
president away for making big Pharma
illegal advertising in America from all
cable TV being done and by the way all
it takes is one bold crazy president to
do what to do something that's never
been done before now you got 200
countries worldwide 195 to allow big
Pharma to advertise we know the two
we've talked about them plenty of times
New Zealand and U.S if America if a
president in America chooses to do so
you're just going to be another one you
know only other countries New Zealand in
what space does the world follow New
Zealand's Pace no nothing if New Zealand
wants to do it go for it so streaming is
not making it easy for these guys
especially if these Sports guys are
going there and they're getting results
has anyone had a better year oh my than
Lionel Messi I was just gonna say that
World Cup champion winner yeah has has
the opportunity to go to Saudi Arabia
for what 400 hundred million dollars a
year and says nah I'm gonna bet on
myself wow I'm gonna take the upside
with this Apple deal I'm gonna move to
the best city in the world Miami Florida
yeah shout out to Mayor Suarez the best
neighbor in Florida best neighborhoods
um but this is called betting in
yourself and you hit the nail in the
head Tom he was a free agent he'd
already proven himself he was The Joe
Rogan of football and look at him now
baby and he's dominating the MLS right
now like the hottest team on the planet
now you got David Beckham there you got
LeBron there everyone's going to the
games Dave grotman everyone it's the the
greatest show on Turf
and one parting shot on the business
side Pat is sports does well because
nobody fast forwards to the ads
everybody watches live and you end up
watching the ads whereas it's a proven
fact that that only about a quarter of
Americans watch the ads if they're
watching something else what a great
point they usually fast forward yeah
especially if they're watching later and
they're binge watching I only have one
friend that would watch reruns and he
would tell everybody don't tell me I
need the score of what happens Steve no
no he would watch the Miami Heat games
later on when he would come home yep he
would watch it on his Pace yeah record
it not live he liked to watch the games
and no one none of his friends could
tell him what the results were so people
would piss them off
at this point yeah so anyway so that's
that part next story I want to get to is
top fed officials signals interest rates
to stay on hold at September meeting
this is a financial time story uh Vinnie
I'm going to come to you on this one
Christopher Waller a Federal Reserve
officials suggested that the central
bank is likely to keep its Benchmark
interest rate on change at the upcoming
September meaning citing recent economic
data as not warranting imminent monetary
tightening water emphasized there's
nothing that is saying we need to do
anything imminent anytime soon Waller's
remarks echoed Federal Reserve chair Jay
Powell stands at Jackson Hole Wyoming
Symposium emphasizing a data-driven
approach recent labor market reports
indicated a slow slowing demand for
workers in the U.S prompting the FED to
close the amount of inflation indicators
despite improvements in inflation data
water remained cautious emphasizing the
importance of sustained Trends rather
than isolated reports Tom yeah so the
fed's going to get together September
19th and 20th but Jay pal will not be
going upstairs to pound the cheerleader
she's going to get a break rates Jesus
it's um not going to happen however on
on Halloween
Jerome Powell's gonna dress as somebody
and they're going upstairs and unless
some of these soft economic things that
we're seeing we're probably going to get
a quarter point increase on October 31st
and there's a lot of people including me
analysts that believe that will be our
last increase and then we've got to get
through the winter see how Black Friday
and fourth quarter goes and everything
like that but um hoping I'm hoping
there's none on October 31st but it
looks like with the softness we'll
probably get a quarter point but nothing
in the next two weeks which is a good
thing when will be the first decrease I
think the first decrease I'm I'm with
the consensus on this February the
bigger Banks is
um probably April right at the beginning
of second quarter is you get a quarter
point back but here's what it here's
what it needs and it's kind of bad what
it needs is softer consumer spending so
it doesn't drive inflation prices and it
needs a little bit of softness in the
labor market so some layoffs and we're
seeing some of those we need a little
bit more softness and labor market to
keep wages down how much how much of
what Amazon does on Black Friday and
holiday season is going to kind of tell
us where consumer spending is and what
how it's going to dictate interest rates
well I happen to be very interested in
how the hell the US
consumer is going to make Black Friday
crazy when they've now drove their
consumer credit cards up to one trillion
dollars how do they go nuts on Black
Friday this year if if 30 days ago
consumer credit hit the largest total
credit balance of all time yeah I was
just going to go there if you follow the
math
um
so let's just follow some of the numbers
here for a second so the FED funds rate
right is what five and a quarter five
and a half percent right so that's the
rate at which the Fed
lends money to or gives money to the
banks and then the prime rate which is
the the number that banks will use to
basically disperse money the regular
people is usually around three percent
higher than the Fred funds rate so
basically you're talking fed fund rate
five five and a quarter five and a half
to the prime rate which would would you
would receive or businesses would
receive at about eight and a half
there's your mortgages okay there's your
mortgages exactly but you brought up the
best point the average person out there
you talked about that credit card debt
just passed the trillion dollars student
debt's already done it auto loans are
already there uh mortgages are already
10 trillion whatever the number is over
there but speaking of credit card debt
you know they are speaking the prime
rate being eight and a half percent do
you know the average credit card rate in
America today the average take again 24
19 and a half 19.9 20 highest of all
time
um was 17 last year so they're breaking
records these nine type of records that
you want to be breaking if you're an
average consumer so it's very important
just pay attention to the interest rates
there it is right there 20.9 21 if you
just want to round up
okay listen if you're if you're trying
to make money investing a good decent
rate of return would be what ten percent
nine ten percent that's what the stock
market pays over time you're losing
money going the opposite way when you're
trying to go this way it's disastrous
and it's killing your wealth guys
lasagna because I don't want to show off
and get into Finance stuff but
everything that you and Tom said I
concur so that's that's correct
my constituents are 100 I just
appreciate that do you know the cap on
credit card debt with like the highest
they can charge you do you know what it
is no clue 30 wow that's like that's all
that you're they're allowed so right now
you have to be hired let's start a
credit card company well that's a big
business to get into but what they're
starting to do is the the the the level
of Regulation and scrutiny right now
with Visa Mastercard the the world
they're dealing with it's not what it
used to be because a lot of guys see
these numbers and they're like let's go
into the credit card business it's not
what you think it is there used to be a
lot of money in a dude years ago they've
kind of regulations hurt them a little
bit uh it's still profitable but it
takes a lot more to get into it but Rob
can you do me a favor pull up the
Liberty Safe story pull up the Liberty
Safe story on what just happened by the
way very weird story guys on what
happened with Liberty Safe can you just
go pull up what Liberty Safe is some
people have a liberty safe and they
don't maybe you don't know what Liberty
Safe is once you see it go to images
just go to images it's not that song
Liberty Liberty so that's a Liberty Safe
go to their logo okay like I have a
Liberty Safe is that the one you have I
have one of them I have a liberty safe
and I have to but I have a Liberty Safe
okay so you're not so safe yeah so watch
this now go to the story what happened a
credible story been around for a long
time a lot of people uh who are gun
owners trust what Liberty Safe is you
know their history goes years back on
what they've done etc etc I can say a
bunch of things about these guys however
story comes out gun maker gun safe maker
facing backlash for giving FBI access to
customer safe without court order what
Liberty Safe and security products a
popular manufacturer gun saves is facing
heavy criticism for helping the FBI
carry out raid last week on a man who
allegedly participated in January 6
Capital right the company which
advertises itself as America's number
one heavy duty no longer home and gun
safe manufacturer it's about to change
admitted on Wednesday too turning over
the defendant's private access coach to
feds without a court order prompting
backlash and raising questions about why
Liberty Safe even had the codes in the
first place on August 30th Agents from
the Federal Bureau of Investigation FBI
rated and arrested 34-year Arkansas
resident Nathan Houston connection with
the capitol right on January 6 2021
Hughes was served with an arrest Warren
charging him with a felony civil
disorder offense on a misdemeanor a
participation in the two and a half
years since the so-called Insurrection
Deputy has arrested over 700 people
Etc et cetera by the way when you think
about this go a little low Rob if you
can't go a little lower what do
Hodgetwins say there I want to see what
happens
okay so so watch this this is this is
this is a very big deal by the way
do you remember what happened at San
Bernardino shooting yes okay yes so who
who was the president back then that was
Obama Obama was President who did he
allegedly and his Camp call to get there
to break the code to the iPhone Tim Cook
and what did Tim Cook said go to hell go
to hell nope now let's get this straight
Tim Cook was the first openly gay CEO of
a Fortune 500 company in the world to
come out and say I'm gay I'm a CEO and
I'm taking Apple from 100 billion
dollars to a three trillion dollar
company Liberty Safe
if you were to guess which side of the
aisle you think politically most of
their customers are going to be what
would you guess they are I would say I
would say Republicans what a percentage
would you say they're on the right 85
okay let's say 75 plus percent is on the
right what the hell are you thinking
it's a big what are you thinking like so
so now what do you think a customer is
going to look at Liberty Safe and say
what's my alternative aren't these guys
the guys that give up the code to other
people aren't these guys the guys that
give up the code to everyone isn't this
the guy that wait free enterprise free
market companies gonna help the
government so you're going to work
together to get my access yeah I'm sorry
I'm not okay with this what do you think
about when you hear stories like
horrible because think about you're
paying for this service and you're
paying for the privacy and that mind you
besides the fact that the proud boy
situation that's something that we're
going to get into later it's like I
don't care what the situation is getting
into that there's a contract that you
sign when you when you buy this type of
stuff and uh Pat I don't know if you
guys know this or not last night uh they
came out with a a response Liberty Safe
Rob I sent you the photos if you want to
put that up they said we listened to our
brother because they know the Bud Light
situation is about to happen it just
tucked it yeah we listened to our
customers and updated our products and
practices in response to the involving
needs today we are announcing a change
that empowers our customers with the
greater control to exactly too late so
information effective immediately
existing customers can visit uh the
libertysafe.com pages combination
removal and fill out you have to do the
work fill out a form to have records of
their access codes expunged in the
coming weeks and be releasing the
feature that gives you every new
customer this option when registering
their say so basically Pat there they
know they're messing up and they're
going backwards but listen like you just
said it's too late and here's the other
thing they're saying it's an
Insurrection they had to go into the
guys safe if he brought those weapons to
the capital then I'd say put them in
jail but you're going in a safe getting
his code obviously it wasn't out in the
open I don't see that yeah no it's it's
these guys were founded in Rob if you
can go to their Wikipedia Liberty Safe
began operations out of a single storage
unit over the past 30 years the company
has grown from a small facility to 205
000 square foot facility in Utah and can
produce more than 500 safes a day as of
2018 they claim to have sold 2 million
saves during the first 30 years the
company employs 350 people Founder's
name is Jack Crosby I don't even know if
Jack Crosby is still running the company
or not but this is a massive just so you
know Liberty Safe
it may take you years before you gain
the trust back of people about the name
of the CEO that's what I said Jack
Crosby no no no two lines down the CEO
the the key people Joe fail well
um
then the word safe like you're a safe
company now nobody's gonna feel safe
especially when you're giving the FBI
access to you so we have something from
their Marketing Group that says in
response to the controversy we are
changing our name to tyranny unsafe and
our slogan will be when you need to
protect your guns most of the time
nice at least they're being honestly
then I just have a question maybe just
to play devil's advocate for a second
yeah so how does this work is there a
search warrant involved at what point do
they have to open up the safe I'm just
wondering I'm sure they weren't like
excited to do this apple was not charged
they held the ground and said we're not
going to give you a we are not giving
this up because good thing about Adam
regardless of the situation proud boys
or whatever we're talking about
Insurrection right nobody was shot the
only person that was shot and killed was
a United States military female veteran
so I don't know what what does he have
in there the the the map and the the
diagram of the capital it's it's
ridiculous and I'm I'm happy that
they're being exposed and yeah I agree
that's going to take them a long time
although you have that big safe Pat you
have a safe size of you it's a Liberty
City it's a massive Liberty that's the
first thing I did something happen with
the say if we couldn't open it no no
yeah of course yeah but Brown so just so
you know
Browning safe is a competitor of theirs
and there's a couple other ones Fort
Knox is another one Browning safe is one
of them uh they they Browning has been
around for 145 years since 1878 and
what's so funny is they're all side of
Utah so both companies are out of Utah
Browning and uh Liberty Safe so if we go
to Fort Knox uh go go look to see how
long Fort Knox has been around I would
invest in them today Pat like think
about it I would invest in them and I
would put a promo for the if I was them
right now I'd be like hey guys guess
what you want your stuff safe come to
come to Browning safe yeah Brownies so
but what's the Fort Knox save can you
look at their history on how long
they've been around at this point I'm
actually really curious to know how long
they've been around gun safes uh uh uh
what is the year if you do have it Rob
uh let me see this
um is it shown on their website
on what it is if you go to about us
anyways
1892 1890 1982 so so Browning is in the
1800s uh Fort Knox is 1982. this other
one is also in the 80s uh Liberty Safe
big miss this is big Miss I mean look is
it gonna make you think twice you go to
the store to buy safe you see Liberty
Safe you see Browning you see uh Fort
Knox who are you gonna buy not Liberty
how about that yeah whatever you want
Liberty does it does it change your
influence Tom you're a gun owner
completely changes my influence because
I look at it this way I'm thinking two
steps ahead you know your next five
moves yeah I have a thing called your
next five thoughts I'm like what if they
have a rogue employee that's just go get
my access code and get my address off
the warranty card and come over and
steal my that's the point yeah
they're carrying these codes that
doesn't make me feel good you know what
it does do it gives you so much more
respect for Tim when Tim Cook didn't
give anything to Obama I agree I agree
it gives so much more respect for Tim
Cook and by the way this leads me into
what's going on with China what China
announced with apple if he can pull this
up Rob China has just imposed an
immediate ban on all Apple devices by
government officials
uh Apple's the largest company in the
world and 96 of their products are
manufactured in China let me say this
again 96 of their products are
manufactured in China if you go to read
the story against the backstroke of the
tensions between Beijing and Washington
the extension of abandoned posts for
more than two years ago signaling grown
challenges in the U.S which relies
heavily on China for Revenue growth and
Manufacturing staff in the three
Ministries and government bodies were
told not to use iPhone at work said the
sources who declined to be named due to
their sensitivity of the situation one
of the sources that they had not yet
been given a deadline to seize their
iPhone Apple and China State Council
information office which handles media
queries on behalf of the government did
not immediately respond to requests for
comment it was not immediately clear how
widely the ban was being enforced with a
third Source uh at one of the three
Ministries saying he still was using an
iPhone and had not heard about the
Restriction of Ford Source at a Chinese
regulatory body said they had not been
explicitly banned but were told they
would be held responsible should any
issue emerge with the use of their
iPhone and a fifth Source said at
another regulatory body says senior
staff had two years ago already been
required to swap their iPhones for
locally made Brands such as Huawei
Technologies uh what else do we have
under 2020 Chinese okay go a little or
Rob to see if there's anything else
there can you do me a favor in terms of
reporter China planned to broaden the
ban uh okay Bloomberg on Thursday
reported that China planned to broaden
the ban to State firms and agencies
citing sources let's see what Apple
stock is doing based on this
announcement did it do anything to Apple
stock today
go to Apple stock today it's down 3.2
percent okay Apple stock is down 3.2
percent which three point two percent
may not seem like a lot of money but 3.2
percent is roughly uh 3 trillion you got
the 10 would be 300 billion three
percent would be 30 billion dollar loss
today
what is the reasoning behind why don't
Apple lost 30 billion dollars today they
lost the Snapchat
they lost a Snapchat today wow that's
hilarious they lost the Snapchat what do
you think what do you think is behind
the not using a phone that's made in
that country is it for security are they
watching you are you on the internet are
you well what there's a lot of different
things going on here one Tim Cook slowly
moved 25 of his structure to India like
to manufacture and he wanted to do in
India and then even Apple ended up
having some friction with India if you
go back and Rob type in Tim Cook Apple
India there was some problems there
um you know manufacturing that they're
going back and forth and so when you say
you're moving gradually some of your
business outside of China China's
sitting there saying wait a minute
decoupling all these years we gave you
all this business now you want to move
out to a different place what are you
doing and but the reality of it is Tim
Cook has to do this and he has to do it
in such a subtle patient way knowing if
there is a man a CEO in the world that's
walking on eggshells and has been
walking on eggshells for the last two
years it's Tim Cook imagine you're a
three trillion Auto Company all eyes on
you okay you're trying to move 96 of
your manufacturing is made in China
after covet China showed how much
control they had of course around the
world the control with the chips and
you're like hey guys we have to slowly
don't tell anybody we gotta move this
out how are we going to do this 96 to a
different place I don't know but we have
to do it and we have to do it slowly by
the way just something crazy to be
thinking about do you you know the new
iPhone is coming out in the next couple
weeks yes do you know how much it's
going to be I heard it's more than a
MacBook Pro no no no no no no no put the
new iPhone price you know right oh you
heard about this right it's going to be
the most expensive iPhone ever ever
it's going to be the most expensive
iPhone ever if you can just find that
the most recent story Rob on how much
they're selling it at there's stories of
it don't go to stores Go to stories go
to news go to news all the way at the
top yeah it's not showing you anything
okay so what's the average price I
listen the stories I've heard is 35 more
than it usually is that's what I've
heard and I may be wrong but I've heard
it's going to be pretty high and uh I
don't know if this has anything to do
with that scroll down a little maybe go
a little lower right there iPhone 15
will be starting at 7.99
you might buy like 15 Pro Max starts at
thirteen hundred dollars and it can go
as high as two thousand dollars what I'd
rather get a computer you'd rather get a
Macbook which you have to also realize
if apple is having to move this stuff
out they don't have a choice but to have
to raise prices so a lot of people want
this thing to be made in America We Can
Make It in America for three times the
price you okay with that four thousand
dollars
that's another real quick quick one here
on India so not only do they want to
move to India so that they can
manufacture and they can balance the
risk of Chinese manufacturer and things
like that like a conservative president
putting tariffs and things like that so
Tim Cook's trying to do that but what is
Tim Cook's market share today in India
that's a very good question 5.1 percent
it is 95 Android so if you want to keep
growing you have to open new markets you
have to find new consumers and there's a
big stack of them sitting in India so
they want to make the phones there and
they also want to break open into the
India market and have more successes
there's a big there's only one big
problem with India okay what India is
not China let me explain what I mean by
this India has is is one of the only big
countries in the world that's a ban tick
tock the India's banned 100 uh what do
you call it Chinese apps in India India
doesn't give a about America or
China they're not playing the card of
being controlled and being bought they
they've seen what happened to other
places they do not the the benefit India
has is they're 10 years behind China
right whether it's with their roads
whether it's with their internet whether
it's with their Broadband their
Broadband sucks by the way in India and
they don't have a lot of different
markets infrastructure is a mess over
there right schooling all of that
hospitals airports ports period they
have a lot of problems but the benefit
of being 10 years behind is gives you
what growth you you know you get to see
all the mistakes they made and you get
to see the relationship between China
and U.S to say look those are 19
mistakes China made those are 17
mistakes us made guys we're not going to
be doing this because we do not want to
be in control like America and we don't
want to be losing trust around the world
like China did let's move a little bit
more strategically that's the edge India
I believe has and then don't forget
India is the largest democracy in the
world under Modi right and everything
they're doing China is still
CCP communism state-run capitalism
wherever you want to put it
back to the Tim Cook Apple thing
I don't know what kind of responsibility
do you take for moving 97 of your
manufacturing over to a communist
country so you can get some cheap child
labor respect but I don't know there's
some level accountability has to pay for
it you talked about we got to quietly
move things out to India uh they're well
aware they're watching everything
yeah exactly you know I love this I love
this uh Insider article it says China
may now never take over the U.S Crown as
the world's largest economy so that's
big news ever since we've been focusing
on the China issue ever since we started
the podcast 2020 I've been like holy
China they're coming for us China
China 2025 China 2030 they're coming for
us but kovid has basically allowed the
world to be like what's really going on
in China right now good and what have we
seen tourism tourism has plummeted
investments in the country has plummeted
businesses are slowly stealthily moving
out of there but the biggest thing that
China has lost is trust the world don't
trust you Xi Jinping the world is fully
aware of what you got going on now and
now whether it's stealthily or openly
people are like I'm getting the hell out
but let me let me address the first
question which is a very valid question
you brought up I'm Tim Cook it is on Tim
Cook to have the answer to the question
why is 96 of your manufacturing for
Apple being done in China very fair
question okay
he's come back I don't know what his
answer is going to be I'm not going to
speak on his behalf but this is what I
would be thinking I would say when we
first started doing business with China
China didn't have the kind of lack of
trust in the world that they do today
what did you want me to do we've been
doing business with China for many many
years and all of a sudden we're so In
Too Deep because we were able to make
nice margins deliver the product for
people we were able to get you know as
many iPhones that people wanted to order
no other country could move this fast
not including America not including this
at the price that you want and for us to
get our margins so he when you're in too
deep in a relationship like that you
know in today's economy let's just say
Tim is starting Apple today and Steve
Jobs just came out with the iPhone today
or the iPod today or the I touch today
whatever the new product is he's
probably in today's climate not signing
a manufacturing deal with China but this
is a relationship that's been going on
for decades with China way before they
were a scary Empire on what they did
with kovid well I totally understand up
I understand that if I may respond uh he
knew he was well aware that it's still a
communist country even if they were you
know had certain capitalist Tendencies
he was well aware but I don't know maybe
I'm just oversimplifying this if I have
an Investment Portfolio if I'm starting
a company or if I'm my own personal
Investment Portfolio I have 60 domestic
stocks I have 25 International I have
five percent bonds I'm putting two
percent of crypto I'm gonna diversify so
just God forbid the US economy goes down
or the Chinese economy goes down what
what there's going to be other asset
classes that go up to go in I don't know
if it's 96 or 97 whatever it is that is
the vast majority of your manufacturer
it works bro well then teach me no it's
not I'm no you're asking the right
question this is when the podcast gets
exciting when we're having these types
of uh exchanges right so I just Googled
when Apple started doing business with
China okay so check this out in 1990 no
it's 2001 believe it or not was further
back right so if you if you Google Rob
when did Apple start doing business with
China that's exactly the words it'll
come up in 2001 Apple brokered a
partnership with China
Apple broker to deal with China the
government poured billions of dollars
into a new infrastructure for Apple
building factories Paving New Roads uh
constructing housing for Apple workers
Kate Whitehead helped oversee Apple's
operations in China now watch this when
did Steve Jobs die probably right around
then nope he died in 2011 10 years later
really okay yes so meaning not even 10
years or 12 years yes so so the point
the point is this is under Steve Jobs
when you're in China and China and Steve
everybody thought China was the way to
go back in the days China was like the
future Frontier you know Richard Nixon
broken the deal everything is good we're
all doing business Ray dalius hardcore
Pro China One of the interviews I did
with Steve Ray dalio we talked about
China was not the friendliest interview
it was very uncomfortable talking about
China because he was defending China and
I'm like wait a minute America First
over China but the moral of the story is
when you're in too deep like that and by
other one did they launch iPhone what
year did they launch iPhone what year
was iPhone launched I'm actually curious
2007 2004 I don't I don't know oh seven
okay so 2007 iPhone is launched you
signed a deal with China in 01 2011 jobs
dies you know Tim Cook comes in in 2011
2012. you know you're kind of coming in
and seeing the numbers and then all of a
sudden now you're today Tim Cook has a
very hard job today so what you're
saying is it's not on cook it was on
jobs and now cook is it's his deal is
responsibility I think it's on anybody I
mean we have an insurance company that
we're doing all these policies right so
so yesterday we're having a conversation
with one of our carriers right now that
we've given so much business to that now
it's kind of like you know you have to
make the adjustments where somebody
doesn't have that much market share 96
is very scary very very scary I I very
uncomfortable
it's very uncomfortable
six percent of php's business went to so
I'm saying
this is a great conversation to have is
what I'm saying to you it's a very good
conversation to have right now with this
okay any any comments so we go to the
next story okay let's go to the next
story here all right so next story uh um
BMW Mercedes-Benz launch biggest EV push
yet to catch Tesla they're new models
let's go to uh page number six BMW
Mercedes are aggressively entering the
electric vehicle Market to counter
competition with Tesla and Chinese
contenders at the IAA Mobility Motor
Show they revealed significant
development unveiling electric concept
cars and advanced EV platforms to
solidify their presence in the EV domain
Mercedes introduced A New Concept CLA
class
an electric vehicle built on new
architecture featuring a remarkable
range of 750 kilometers and the
capability to achieve 400 kilometers
range within a 50-minute charge
Mercedes-Benz CEO Ola uh kalinios
emphasized a revolutionary nature of the
car stating with those efficiency
numbers that kind of range that kind of
fast charging I'm not aware of any
vehicle in that class that can match it
on the other hand BMW showcased the
vision new class a new electric concept
car that underlines the company's EV
Ambitions and introduce a new platform
for EVS Rob can you show the picture of
that Mercedes-Benz they're talking about
let's see what it looks like uh Tom go
forward what are your thoughts when you
hear this story here well first of all
everyone's caught up with making cars
with Tesla and they're cute on the
little side and they're gorgeous on the
big side and they're going farther than
ever which now they're able to get over
um uh 300 miles pretty pretty regularly
with the Battery Technology what's funny
in this is all the headlines are
Elon Musk has finally been caught by all
the automakers finally he's going to
take it in the chops on this well on
June 16th Ford came to Elon Musk and
said we'd like to sign a contract with
you so that our people have been asking
us a question since buying Ford
Lightning pickups uh outside of my
garage where do I plug the son of a
in and Tesla has 12 000
superchargers across the United States
then in July Mercedes before these
announcements were made said yeah can we
borrow your superchargers so that's now
built into the Mercedes credit card when
you get a Mercedes it's electric and you
go charge at a Tesla it automatically
charges to you and then seven car makers
got together including Hyundai Kia and
BMW and announced
seven years after Elon Musk started
building electric gas stations they
announced we're going to build a chain
of our own as well and so what I think
is really interesting is electric cars
have never been better we're living in
the Golden Age of electric vehicles
right now they're beautiful look at this
they're Advanced the chips the chips and
everything we were talking about Nvidia
the other day and you just look at
what's in there they're just gorgeous
but plugging them in and keeping them
going even when they go 300 miles is
another thing and the other side of
Tesla they're an energy company and so
he's a gas station for everybody else so
I like to say Elon Musk started a war
for razors but he's out there selling
razor blades gotta love it I love I love
that he's doing that I will tell you a
couple different things here Tom to be
considering with this number one
capitalism works you know uh the
competitors are probably watching Tesla
and seeing a CEO that's a bit distracted
because he's dealing with a bigger
problem which is Twitter and his focus
is no longer one-dimensional focus on on
a company anytime somebody's 100 focused
on one company no matter how smart you
are no matter how brilliant you are no
matter how sharp you are you're always
going to beat the competitor if you're
100 focused on one item one project then
you are on dealing with a lot of
different things so when he was focused
on Tesla you know great it's a
formidable competitor so capitalism seen
that as an opportunity to capitalize
number two
is the following who do you think has a
high ESG score BMW
Mercedes-Benz or Tesla not Tesla it's
not even a question so BMW
Mercedes-Benz all of these guys when a
book comes out when a when a business
book comes out I'll never forget what
our publisher said to us I'm not going
to name the publisher and please don't
say what publisher if I'm saying this
so if a publisher comes out to us and
say hey Pat the position you're taking
I'm telling you right now New York Times
no matter if you sell a hundred thousand
cop is your first month by the way your
next five moves I couldn't even believe
it if you go on Amazon right now type in
your next five moves the book I've not
promoted this book for God knows I don't
even know when's the last time I brought
up your next five moves on this podcast
the book go to your next five moves and
go to audible uh if you can just go on
Audible click on the book and then go on
Audible right in the middle and then go
all the way on the bottom ranking Okay
click on audiobooks and go all the way
in the bottom and then zoom in a little
bit on the ranking zoom in a little bit
right there right there zoom in a little
bit it's right above your rap go a
little Rob zoom in right there right
there bro stop the screen right there
Jesus Rob oh Rob right there thank
you God number Rob you're on it just
zoom in it says book seller ranking to
the left top left oh my God scroll up a
little bit right there yeah out of 10
million audiobooks it's ranked 146 today
wow how this high ice at several ranks
since we launched the book three years
ago I don't even know why it's ranked
we've not sold this book a single time
right
but here's the part the publisher said
something very interesting to me he said
Pat if
you want this book to be a New York
Times bestseller just know they're not
going to pick a guy like you to be on
the New York Times bestseller list
you're just not going to be because
you're not Their audience okay so then
we had tubing here Jeffrey tuben who's
here okay the magic book his book his
book doesn't make it On The Wall Street
Journal and because you know the Wall
Street Journal goes based on numbers
being sold New York Times doesn't go
based on numbers being sold New York
Times goes based on likability and they
value you Wall Street journalists you
sold numbers you're ranked we get the
report New York Times like you need more
than just numbers we're looking for you
being this and you being that and you'll
be in this okay wow so what lists and
and media companies you think are gonna
write positive by the way here his book
came out May 2nd 2023 it's you know uh
these books become New York Times
bestsellers I don't know if this one but
his last two or three became New York
Times bestsellers chapter six and seven
are stuck together that's right I
remember that yeah horrible so so but
here's the point here's the point what
magazines websites articles you think
are going to write positively about
Tesla then which one I mean number one
EV in the world Tesla no no this is all
opinion by the way so when it comes down
to opinion who's going to be at the top
Mercedes you're gonna have BMW you can
have anybody which is ironic because
they come from the Germany regime they
don't care about that they don't know
anything but Tesla elon's a Nazi yeah we
love Mercedes
from there right yeah yeah but if we
have changed yeah so when when you think
about this part what do you think about
competition who has an advantage they
have a massive Advantage you know when
we lead into the next story here uh next
story being about uh uh the gentleman
that was interviewed Larry who was
interviewed on Tucker Carlson right
loosen up my time so this story and by
the way a lot of people are infuriated
with Tucker Carlson interviewing this
guy why would you do this why would you
do this Barack Obama has has not been a
president for this many years shame on
you Tucker you're just doing it for
eyeballs I think I heard John Stewart if
he can pull up Jon Stewart uh it wasn't
even John Stewart I think I saw another
person that said his failed propaganda
show on Twitter
propaganda show on Twitter after getting
fired from Fox so that's the that's the
storyline on what they're saying right
but anyways he interviews this guy bit
risky Rob I think you brought him up to
us like a month ago didn't you bring
this up a month I didn't want to sit in
a meeting he actually did Larry
months ago right and what did you say I
said I said not right now I'm like not
right now okay so so but the story comes
out that Obama you know that Tucker
Carlson claims Obama spoke uh smoked
crack and had gay sex okay
let me read this properly on page eight
folks if you got kids listening tell
them to go have ice cream and stuff away
for a few minutes okay all right here we
go
Tucker Carlson during an interview with
uh Dave Portnoy revived Larry Sinclair's
claim stating in 2008 it became clear
that Barack Obama had been having sex
with men and smoking crack Carlson noted
that Sinclair signed an affidavit and
then underwent a lie detector test
saying I smoke crack where Barack Obama
and had sex and that was obviously true
Carlson criticized the media's handling
of the allegations saying that the Obama
campaign threatened to deny access to
anyone reporting on the claims he
emphasized nobody reported on it because
they were squeamish about sex or drugs
but because the Obama campaign said
anyone who reports on this gets no
access to Obama's campaign so no one
talked about it and this guy was seen as
a cuckoo crazy you know a drug addict
he's got a big criminal record and if
you go back look at his criminal record
it's between 1980 to 1986 and he does
have some things but it's mainly during
that era so they have to undermine him
now here's the thing I don't know if
it's true or not I'm purely going based
on speculation one question I have is
why is Tucker do doing it now is it
because he's now free and he's able to
do whatever he wants to do and he wanted
to do this at Fox and Foxwood and allow
him to interview this guy and report him
that could be one reason too what other
motive does he have to want to get under
Obama's skin today and it's a trending
topic all over Twitter okay when you see
something like this what are your
thoughts on this story um well first of
all
barack's a little he's a little rascal
that guy besides the drugs and all that
stuff let's just really break let me be
clear yeah uh first of all that the the
knight in question the Larry Sinclair
pack he's visiting his godson he's
graduating from the military Naval thing
he gets a limo he leaves he asked the
limo driver hey I'm I want to hook up
with dudes and I want to do drugs the
limo driver goes I have the spot and I
know some people so this is like he's
delivering gay guys to Barack almost
like Uber Eats but for gay men it's like
uber this is in uh Chicago in Chicago so
uh no yeah in Chicago so guys he brings
him their path he gets brought they have
some drinks he does he's doing cocaine
with him on a CD thing Barack pulls out
a pipe and he smokes it and even Larry
Sinclair is like to each his own
whatever they start getting down in the
limo but here here's the thing where
people are like why do you care and and
listen let's just I'll get to that point
but let's go I did a timeline that of
suspect suspect activity and first of
all yesterday Michelle Obama knowing
that this interview was coming out she
traveled to Majorca Spain and spent time
with her close friends Jamie Costa and
his Husband Michael Smith a gay couple
without Barack Barack stayed back all
right let's go do the timeline 1999 he
smokes crack with Larry Sinclair who
mind you Pat sign the affidavit and pass
the lie detector test I don't know if
any of you guys have taken lie detector
tests I have in the military you're not
a guy some random dude that's gay and
does drugs and he's not passing it past
CIA operatives know how to pass it
because they train to pass it okay so I
think his his claim is is legit uh let's
go to 2007 a choir director at Barack
Obama's Church Donald Young Who
allegedly knew about Obama and his
homosexuality lifestyle was murdered in
Chicago in his apartment he was shot
multiple times at close range twice in
the head no signs of force and uh entry
the door was unlocked but close the
neighbors said they didn't have a
gunshot all right Fast Forward 2014 Joan
Rivers TMZ asked her on camera if the
country was ready for the first gay
president and what did she say we
already have one with Obama and Michelle
Obama is a transgender two weeks later
she dies on an operating table on a
routine medical procedure fast forward
uh July uh 23 2023 uh Obama's personal
chef Safari Campbell a self-proclaimed
trained swimmer was found dead at
Martha's Vineyard right by the Obama
State allegedly he was paddle boarding
and eight feet of water and he drowned
he was found naked and his clothes were
like a far distance away and we still
they won't let us know who he was paddle
boarding with oh and by the way Michelle
and Iraq initially they said that they
weren't on the island they were there
and photo surface Pat where Brock had a
black eye but nobody nobody got into
that situation brokeback Vineyard
exactly exactly and lastly just recently
old Love Letters from 1982 resurfaced
that Barack wrote to his then College
sweetheart Alexandra McNair and in one
of those leaders he wrote and I quote in
regard to homosexuality I must say that
I believe this is an attempt to remove
oneself from the present a refusal
perhaps to perpetrate the endless farce
of Earthly life you see I make love to
men daily in my imagination he tells her
this and here's my thing Pat I can care
less that if you're gay if you're not I
I don't care but if you're holding on to
that secret and you've been lying to us
all this time because technically if
this is all true which I believe in this
guy this guy has no clue why is Larry
Sinclair he's been saying this Pat mind
you since the early 80s he went in front
of in Washington he told everybody
he's broke he doesn't he doesn't give a
damn if they're lying about that what
else what else do you like lying about
what about what about those emails that
Wikileaks Julian Assange leaked with
John podesta and Hillary and all these
guys were blocking them or talking about
pizza Pat deliver let's deliver 65
000 worth of pizza at one o'clock in the
morning and then they call us conspiracy
theorists just be out when open because
guess what congratulations you'd be the
first gay president do it come out say
it what like what anyway what anyway
that anyway you you're like you don't
believe any of it that anyway was I
don't believe it I believe that everyone
should have the ability to speak nobody
should be canceled yes including wild
conspiracy theorists
okay so all those things I'm just saying
everyone is entitled to what they you
know to their
opinion yeah you know I love that we
have you know conspiracy theorists on
the show who's the people who's the
consumer we've had Alex Jones we've had
uh how much how much of his theories
that you would say well there was that
one thing that he kind of figured out so
he just he can't mess up ever no but but
a lot of them are right some of them
have been right the water turns the
Frog's gay obviously but then there was
that one thing okay all right it cost
him a billion dollars yeah
but all right so it seems like you're
taking the stance that Obama is
definitely getting I would put I would
put all my money on the he's 100 what
are the chances you just said 100 I
would put all my money so when there's
smoke Adam this is fine this is the
problem that I have I wouldn't really I
wouldn't put a hundred and I put I
wouldn't put zero anytime that you're
like definitely 100 yeah there's no
question I'll put every amount of money
on it okay let's just back up a second
because we're talking about this guy
Larry Sinclair yeah so what you're
saying is we all of a sudden now believe
a gay crackhead uh Obama blowing drug
dealer criminal he's not a deal it
wasn't a dealer drug user he used my bad
video dealing okay whatever who's a
known Satanist okay what's okay okay go
ahead allegedly alleged allegedly who
has been with a 27-year criminal history
not 27. oh so now you're layers did you
did you watch the video last night you
watch the video the whole hour no I'm
not gonna spend an hour online I was
studying the economy I was studying
Trump but that's the problem Adam you
didn't you didn't you didn't see
anything that's true you know what I did
do I did spend some time uh reviewing
his rap sheet so he spent time in jail
uh in Colorado South Carolina Florida
Arizona I did spend 16 years in jail he
said 97 run-ins with the law uh he has
been arrested hold on Ben 16 years no he
wasn't he's been arrested for forgery
fraud disorderly conduct and larceny uh
by the way there's now rumors saying
that he's terminally ill so he's going
out with a bang he's got nothing to lose
so listen if you want to go on I
literally I'm saying this With all
sincerity go there all good okay I'm
just inclined not to believe this guy so
so wait so here's my question if let's
just say I saw something happen okay
just because I've been to jail doesn't
take away the fact and I want you to
explain something to me Adam 97 run-ins
with the laws you said there's smoke
there's fires well here's the thing Adam
how do you how how can that guy pass a
lie detector test I don't know if you've
ever well I haven't read about that and
allegedly you can't use the word
allegedly but it the the polygraph test
is what it's called came back as it
indicated deception so do some more
research find out what actually happened
he passed and signed an affidavit Adam
okay don't just say so wait so all the
so all I don't have an agenda I love you
brother are you clearly have an agenda
no I don't know
that Obama is gay
there's no application take a cold
plunge what can I take one thing don't
forget your thing Patrick if I if you
had ten thousand dollars cash right now
and somebody said you have to bet one
way or the other you can't take the
money whatever you win you win do you
think Obama's gay I would love to hear
Pat's answer go ahead if you hold on I
love this smart hold on Rob can you tour
Dash something I'm asking everybody this
question Tom be ready for this Patrick
10 grand you are not leaving this room
unless you make a decision and if you
win you get to take the money and you go
you know what you just reminded you ever
seen the movie Couples Retreat yeah if a
guy had a gun through your head is this
marriage gonna work out or no taught me
right now you don't put a gun to you if
you're you're a therapist had on the
first time yeah if you are the jacket
yeah
go ahead I don't know I I will give you
ratio I won't give you a bet like that
10 grand is not gonna do anything but if
I give you a percentage of these guys
having this experience together I don't
know 30 percent I would say or even that
high yeah thirty percent thirty percent
but but here hear me out yeah hear me
out on why I'm saying 30 is not actually
that high what's confusing for me is the
final one why are people on the left so
worried if he's gay that's what I'm
asking why are people on the left so
like what is wrong with being gay uh
leftists huh Mr Democrats yeah aren't
you guys lgbtq aren't you guys like what
is wrong with being okay it's okay I'm
sorry
Republican shouldn't shouldn't shouldn't
Democrats come out in support of saying
Hell yeah we got a gay President
congratulations why are you all of a
sudden anti-gay why are Democrats all of
a sudden so concerned about the
president being gay everything you're
doing in California with all the
schooling all the indoctrination all you
want more people to be gay so guess what
you finally have a guy that's you know
stores are coming out saying that he may
be yeah I care are you gay so so and
then you know for for for the other part
on you know stories this is the part
that's just uh says why you know BMW and
Mercedes are you're you know trying to
compete with uh Tesla and all this stuff
the left doesn't want to hear the story
if this person the lady came out saying
rape is not about physical rape is about
thought and Anderson Cooper's like uh we
got to go to story I'm really enjoying
this conversation let me get this
straight you will give that person the
psycho lady you'll give that person air
time to interview them but you're not
going to be interviewing this guy got it
you already lost a lot of credibility
with me so you're full of what is
the difference between those two people
that person's got credibility this
person's got credit no or you pick and
choose your stories you're not
journalists you are campaign managers
for a person you like that's part of
your political party they lose
credibility there with this guy I
watched him here's what he looked like I
mean I'm just gonna give you what my I
watch the entire interview by the way
just to kind of get a feel on whether I
believe him or not like when I watch
Karen McDougall okay and she said
I'm convinced we loved each other I
don't know if you've seen the interview
with Carol McGregor supermodel Playboy
girl who allegedly had sex allegedly
allegedly by the way 100 what did I say
when Karen McDougall come up what was my
belief I believed her yeah I said yeah I
believe she loved him and I actually
believe she still loves him okay because
I'm going based on what I saw and my
percentage on that one is like 70
percent okay where I saw that I'm saying
on this one 30 I watched a guy
and you know when you're running an
insurance company or sales company with
a bunch of sales guys your job is to
know which one of your sales people are
full of and which one's not no I
didn't sign that forgery I would never
do that you're like yeah bro I don't
believe you okay I don't believe you and
you take the paper and you put it on top
and you're like nah this is definitely
forgery guys I'm sorry this guy's gonna
lose his license you screwed up you
shouldn't have done that too oh my God I
was just afraid I you know I'll admit to
it and I said dude I can't protect you
now because now Department of Insurance
got involved in the insurance carriers
got involved they have you on freaking
recording multiple times what are you
doing done right my job is to our job as
compliance is to watch now it doesn't
mean we get it 100 that's why there's
investigation all this other stuff
I watched this guy I mean look if even
if you're terminally ill it's not this
the first time he's coming out with the
story 25 years ago 25 years in
Washington yeah so he came out with the
story years ago and you know he's coming
out with it again it's not like it's
last minute so even to say he's
terminally ill that's more of a reason
to say you want your legacy to be there
lies the man that gave a president a
like is that your legacy so what
is it going to say on your Tombstone
right cracking right that's
your Tombstone is that what you want
your legacy to be walking by mom who is
this what is a blow you know you're
gonna have to kind of go through that
yeah so no I don't know I think uh you
know there's a part of it that's true
and to me you know I don't know a lot of
presidents I don't know a lot of men who
you know accidentally call their wives a
man's name two three times and I don't
know I don't know a lot of people that
make mistakes like that I just don't
um you know I've never called Jennifer
Joe I've never I've never said hey you
know and Joe and I you know the other
day I've never done that who did Barack
call Michael he's called Mike he said
hold on Michelle but but but many times
many many times
so you want him to begin no I don't Adam
for me all I'm saying is I'm staying
skeptical
I'm staying skeptical and to be quite
frankly like the most pathetic thing to
me is that Democrats are embarrassed if
he's gay exactly that tells you how much
of a hypocrite you are that you're now
defending against a person being gay
where to you it's normal to be gay why
do you care so much that's the problem I
have I don't have a problem I have an
issue here guys I'm sorry I'm sorry go
for it and I'm just gonna say something
uh
I I believe these stories just as much
as I believe the stories about Donald
Trump let me explain so by the way I'm
not an Obama guy when how often do you
hear me defend Obama I said I like Bill
Clinton and I like Joe manchin and I you
voted for Obama though
yeah so what does that mean you're an
Obama guy no we're not going to play
this game
you also voted for a Bible for Obama
okay I never let me stick up for my man
Vinnie though they call him a conspiracy
theory that's true mainstream media they
went over Pete tapes mainstream stormy
McDonald's mainstream thank you so that
so my point is this I'm skeptical as
hell when I hear you know Trump has a
love affair with his daughter Ivanka
there's people like oh he probably bangs
his daughter I'm like dude yeah this is
not a thing right okay oh he goes to
these modeling competitions for girls
who are under 18 and he like nah I don't
really think so I do think that Trump
has cheated on his wife
umpteen times and has banged hot porn
star chicks like Stormy Daniels and
models like Karen McDougall I actually
think that's true okay but the point is
not every story you hear is actually
true that's your pushback no what I'm
saying is this I don't think that
Democrats are basically being like how
dare you I don't know I just think
they're like uh here's another
ridiculous story they are that they want
to push and the guys married for the
last 20. that's kind of like that but
let me give the eyes
let me give the complete opposite
argument let me give the complete
opposite argument
this is kind of like a uh uh word comes
out that Ron DeSantis running for
president rumor gets out the first woman
he had sex with is his wife Casey he
lost his virginity to Casey after being
married and conservatives say there's no
way that's true the guy's a player he's
been around here he's a good looking guy
he's an Navy SEAL he's a stud wait a
minute hey many of these Christian guys
you want you know your virginity and
your Bible and all this other stuff why
are you now saying no to this what
happened to your virtue signal on being
Christians that's how pathetic this
argument they're making is that they're
embarrassed about some like this now for
me my question isn't even this forget
about the story I don't wake up in the
morning wondering if Barack Obama's gay
or not that's his wife's problem it's
not my problem they need to figure that
part out my concern is more deeper than
that
your name is Tucker Carlson you got 5
000 people that you can interview that's
going to be interesting people to
interview what the hell are you doing
interviewing this guy thank you that was
my next point but but actually go yeah
why go why why are you doing it that's a
great are you doing it because like
let's go through all different angles
one are you doing it to because well
I've always wanted to do the Century Fox
never let me do it I'm putting it into
you know Fox's face okay cool that could
be a possibility check I believe it two
are you doing it because
you are on the inside and you have
friends across Media Company everywhere
A lot of people that maybe maybe were
editors maybe we're insiders worked at
Fox now they're at CNN now they're at
MSNBC and somebody saw a memo or a link
or story or a conference call or meeting
that leaked and the door wasn't fully
closed that said hey Michelle Obama's
running for office okay what happened
nothing I'm asking Rob to do a poll to
see if our audience thinks Obama so I
already did here I will tell you that we
uh we have 2 000 over 2 000 votes 77
percent of the audience believes that
Barack Obama smoke crack in that gay sex
now I know who
voted for Democrat president you're a
registered Democrat no you've always
voted for Democratic president I'm a
registered voted for Republican
president no don't hide around the bush
you never have you've always voted for
left so that's the point I'm a
registered independent but you can do
you think I was gonna vote for fun you
can you think I was going to vote for
fun you can be registered anything I'm
an independent you're a Democrat you
voted Democrat your entire you're a
republican not voted for Clinton
no no because the position you take yes
the position you take what's the
position your position is like I'm not
gonna play this I'm not gonna play this
your political party no your political
party that you voted for your entire
life yes your political party even
though I'm already independent you're a
political party that you have voted for
your entire life is embarrassed of this
story of God forbid Barack Obama being
gay and they're the same ones that push
about people you know supporting lgbtq
what's wrong with that that is that is
absolutely insanely embarrassing from
one perspective okay when I'm giving I'm
being reasonable too saying you Karen
McDougall for me was 780 I'm at 30 with
this guy not a 780 I'm telling you I'm
30. he's at 100 though
if you want him to run a poll text them
say if you want to run a poll I'm making
a point yeah while I'm saying with
Tucker and you causing me to lose my
train of thought I'm in the middle of it
here telling you right now number one is
why is he doing it
you got 5 000 people to choose from they
can't interview so are you doing it
because you want to put it back into Fox
number two are you doing it because
you're worried Michelle Obama's running
for right now for office so it's like
let me kind of put this out there I
don't know is it number three are you
doing number three because Obama never
gave you an interview and you're like oh
okay you don't want to give me an
interview no problem here's what I'm
gonna do to you I don't give a if I
ever interview you here's my Vengeance
back at you great number four are you
doing it because mainstream media
covered everything on Russia collusion
for three and a half years and smart
guys like him believed it and many other
people believed that that was actually
happened until three and a half years
later report comes out oh it never
happened it was actually funded by
Hillary Clinton oh move on let's go to a
different story and we have to all the
follow lead and move to the next door
yeah maybe that's why you're doing it
because mainstream media was full of
during covet and there's a couple
people that lost a lot during covet one
of them is mainstream media they lost
credibility never has the word fake news
been used until kovitz showed up and
Trump showed up and Russia showed up and
then people realize you know what this
fake to fake news thing is is real
credibility of how much Americans
believe the media is the lowest it's
ever been not not in the last 10 years
not in the last 20 it's ever been in the
history of America because they're full
of and the American people are sick
of it and you're starting to notice
people are going to get their news from
a freaking podcast we're not journalists
we didn't go to Columbia University and
be fed the same that everybody
else is being fed we're sitting here
like regular people saying why the hell
are you lying to us so much are we
supposed to believe all of this stuff is
throwing you only investigate the people
from one side and not the other side is
that what we're supposed to sit here and
believe now we also want to ask certain
questions I don't know why Tucker did
this interview I this makes no sense to
do this yeah of course do you think this
helps or hurts Tucker's credibility
I I don't think it helps
I don't think it helps I'm a reasonable
guy to tell you this I don't think I
don't I don't like when Rob brought the
story to me and he says Pat it's going
to get a lot of eyeballs and we got to
do this I'm like
I I don't know if I'm interested okay I
don't know if I'm interested and
remember Rob I said something like that
to you if you remember this I mean you
know we're obviously throwing your job
is to give different stories right and
we've discussed at similar things where
it's personal lives that don't matter
like the Dylan danis thing we we yeah
responding you said I'm not interested
another story I will say that only you
and I know this were were guys like hey
this is what really happened to my
relation do you know which one I'm Tom
I'm not going to say the name but you
know exactly what I'm I'm like I'm not
interested bro I called the guy back I'm
like I'm not even gonna talk about it
that's not my interest okay that's your
problem between you and your wife you
guys go figure it out now if you
are making it so crazy that we have to
freaking touch it because you're putting
it out there they're not mistakes on you
in situation like this I don't know if
I'm interested in this story uh is it
entertaining does it get eyeballs I'm re
I'm really
I'm really curious
why you would do it uh uh don't
speculate why you can speculate yeah you
can speculate uh you hit the nail in the
head eyeballs how much was Tucker
Carlson's uh contract at Fox
a year 40 million a year was it no
whatever no it's like 20 million 20
million yeah how much is his contract at
Twitter he doesn't he's not making
anything bingo
so he's in the eyeball game before now I
mean he's the number he's the number one
uh let's just say
talking head I don't think that Tucker
Carlson can be considered a journalist
at this point I could I would I would
say he's a pundit right because they
pundit their job is to Give opinions uh
this is not a factual story this is an
opinion story this is a guy who at the
very least can we agree that this guy
may have some credibility issues
I'm not in your Camp what I'm saying is
this I think Tucker is an absolute
investigative journalist I think Tucker
is doing the right thing interviewing
this guy I think others should have
interviewed this guy 15 years ago during
the election and talked to him about it
after he did a lie detective test out
all I'm trying to find out is why you're
doing it today this should have been
interviewed a long time I think this is
a
Miss and the the job of the people of
mainstream media that never wanted to
talk to this guy because they were
afraid of losing and you know
credibility and relationship with you
know Obama the person they all feared
that they wanted Obama to invite him to
their birthday party and their annual
celebration or their inauguration or all
that other stuff there is a lot of clout
and being in those types of meetings to
say I got an invite from Obama Obama was
a Ronald Reagan figure for the left he
was he was admired and loved by a lot of
people on the left and most people fear
losing something to a guy like this so
for me uh yeah I do think Tucker is an
investigative journalist much better
than a lot of the guys on the left I
would give a you know I would put a
couple guys on the left that I respect
that are doing investigative journalism
and I would put Tucker on that list as
well my question isn't to lose
credibility for that I don't know why
he's doing it now he may have a very
valid reason for doing it and by the way
it could also be a reason that's none of
our business
he could also be doing it to say who the
hell are you for me to have to explain
to you why I'm doing it I'm freaking
doing it because I want to do it and
it's a private matter that I don't even
want to tell the world about it but I
told myself I was going to do this when
I was going to be free and I'm doing it
great more power to you but on paper
um
I I I still don't know the motive behind
doing it now I think that I mean Pat the
great point where I had no idea but
maybe it was the maybe hearing something
about Michelle wanting to make a run
that's gonna you know put us back into
crap because I mean obviously the left
isn't doing a good job but think about
it when was Barack well first president
term when did he become oh wait oh wait
January if they knew the truth and
Sinclair was out and during that time
and putting out these stories that's not
you think that's what you know how they
were covering up this Pat you can't have
he's going to be the first black
president and then all of a sudden oh my
God he's gay as well that's something
where you Americans are ready for that
Americans wanted they still want a
family you know father wife kids it
would have been way too much to put on a
story like Hey listen he's the first
black president oh and by the way he's
gay and just so happens that he's doing
crack in the back of a freaking limo
with somebody Adam I get where you're
coming from and my point is I genuinely
don't care but when the story's out in
your face he's writing letters to his
college girlfriend this is before this
whole situation that he got married
saying I imagine banging dudes in my
head all the time all day this is
written Barack Obama they have it at the
college Occidental College it's a fact
okay these are facts everything that I
said about Joan Rivers and tafari and
all this and all the letters and Brock
and the guy saying look I'm sorry the
truth if he is I'm sorry it hurts if it
hurts people that he's gay oh well
congratulations I think good good for
him well we need a Blue Dress otherwise
they'll never admit it yeah some blue
boxers yeah yeah just yeah we win a
whole damn hour without bringing me into
this bill bill take it easy just build
the night it until though but Pat you
make a great Point what and I you just
woke me up and while you were saying it
I was like oh my God even think about
that what is the motive one of mine was
like did he run out of guests because
think about it sometimes no no okay okay
so that's that's one Tucker when you get
whoever you are
there are certain people when you get an
email from them you respond to that
interview okay there's certain people
you know Tucker's on that top five list
of people that when you get that email
you have to pay attention that's coming
from you which means what
Tucker gets to interview I would say 95
of people in the world you know if he
wanted to talk to them they have to
entertain it and he's got plenty of
options to interview outside of this guy
I just don't know why he did it can I
add one more thing here just for our uh
conspiracy friends out there coincidence
you know we've talked about alliances
being made with obviously Tucker and
Elon on Twitter whatever the Trump thing
is do you know what Elon had to say
about your friend Mr Sinclair this is
Elon Musk who might have a little bit
more knowledge in this General subject
than any of us okay here's what he said
Mr Sinclair is not super convincing pics
or and that's my ultimate Point anyone
can just run with any ridiculous story
spout it out on any ridiculous podcast
and Just Go With It pictures from the
80s 90s yeah yeah there were cameras
back then I don't know if you know that
but if Elon is saying this uh I think
that's fair to say that this probably
lacks credibility well so because he
wants to see Tucker win well 70 77 of
the people that watch one of the dopest
podcasts out business or whatever I
don't think that 77 percent of them are
just crazy conspiracy Kooks they feel it
I could look at it like I could look at
Barack and be like yeah I could see it
there's so they feel it there's a
there's a wallet there's a party room
there's a part of me as well that likes
Elon saying this there's also part of me
that says he has to say this because
he's not got to seal the company that's
like Ilan what are we doing with this
you want me to get advertisers as a
former NBC person Linda yakario you want
me to get all this stuff and we're
putting something like this and you're
retweeting it you have to comment that
you're not fully in it there's there's a
lot of ways to look at this angle on you
know Linda could have told them I'm
about to sign a half a billion dollar
advertising deal with you know 20
different companies what are we doing
here Ilan you're not making me my job
easy I'm trying to hit my bonus those
kinds of conversations I just want to
know is is since Tucker's no longer with
Fox he's basically doing whatever he
wants you know is do you think he's like
the white Tupac
is he the white Tupac
I uh I uh I think he's absolutely
gangster and I think he's pissed on a
lot of people off and I think you know
how hard it is right now to be Jon
Stewart can you go to the clip of Jon
Stewart where he played the the you know
which one I'm talking about Rob I don't
know if you found it or not just put Jon
Stewart on Tucker Jon Stewart and then
put Tucker Stewart Tucker yeah uh
there's a it just came out yesterday I
want to say with Jon Stewart saying what
he said uh gold no not that one go a
little lower he just recently said
something about Tucker can you go a
little faster go a little faster to see
if it's out there oh no okay no problem
but Tucker said Tucker called him evil
I'm sorry Jon Stewart called the Tucker
evil evil evil he says he's evil he
knows what he's doing etc etc and in a
situation like that's the one right
there if he can play that one yeah go
for it just make it bigger and audio go
for it
to your point though about like a guy
like Tucker Carlson like that's cynical
what he does is is cynical starts with
cynical right and he is the true
motivation for it and and that's what I
mean by the difference between
uh well-intentioned honest brokering
and cynical manipulation yeah I
definitely put him on the evil side I
wasn't going to speak for you but no no
for me I put him in the uh no no
question I feel like he knows exactly
what he's doing is saying no question I
don't feel like he's ignorant about his
messaging and his coding no no no no no
it's all purposeful yeah and it's
marshaling very very malevolent forces
yes no question oh but the Marshall and
very malevolent forces
doj against your opponent like
malevolent forces like using the entire
mainstream media to attack an opponent
and make uh the entire country believe
Russia collusion was real and here's
what's crazy I'm a fan of this guy yeah
I like Jon Stewart okay and I also
happen to like Tucker I like both of
these guys and I love the fact that 20
years ago John went on Tucker's show
trying to bully him
and he leaves this is when Tucker had a
bow tie it's right below it Rob if you
can see him when he had a bow tie on
right there and he's like this is just
awful right this show right there on
rapid fire and he's going through it I'm
not we don't have to play the whole
thing I love the fact that Tucker got us
Redemption because Jon Stewart today is
at a lower level than Bill Maher I think
Bill Maher's kicking Jon Stewart's ass
and people actually from both the left
and the right like hearing Bill Maher
and quite frankly I don't know who wants
to hear from Jon Stewart on the right
except for a few people John sounds more
like somebody that's just defending his
political party to be invited to the
parties and Bill Maher is saying F all
of you okay I don't I think all of you
are full of you know just the other
day Bill Maher talks about Trump on
Rogan yeah oh the whole and then he goes
and talks about talk about Biden
about you I I'm I'm sitting there saying
good for you Bill good for you I want to
kind of hear what you got to say but
anyways that's what I think Bill Maher
has more credibility than any of those
names you just mentioned because he's
willing to call out ready for it both
sides if you just want to play your you
know I'm on this side so this is what
I'm defending or I'm on this side
there's something spending I don't think
that's a true honest broker but that
Tucker story was the biggest comeback
story in media oh huge it canceled his
Show Jon Stewart just everyone mocked
him and then 20 years later great story
good for him coming out and then boom
he's uh runs the number one show for God
knows how many years okay so that's that
part next story uh we can go to is Elon
musk's dad
says he's worried the Tesla CEO might be
assassinated following a report about
his influence on government decisions
okay so let's let's take a look at this
here
and this is an Insider story yes
response Errol musk when asked if he
fears a potential assassination of his
son Elon Musk by the shadow government
stemming from a New Yorker article which
he labels a hit job as per the son
interviewed the New Yorker article
portrays Elon Musk as an unelected
official prompting Pentagon officials to
express unease over his attitude towards
Vladimir Putin and acknowledging
spacex's Starling a satellite's critical
role in Ukrainian conflict Elon musk's
personal security concerns are evident
as he shares how his son's car
faced a crazy stalker situation and his
actions such as requesting an office
bathroom and restricting journalists who
shared an account tracking his private
jet reflecting his complex relationship
with safety measures so Tom what are
your thoughts on this relationship
between Ilana and his dad and what is
that a saying about about Iran's safety
he and his dad are strained I think
everybody's read various comments about
it and you know he's terrible human
being those are pretty heavy words
between a father and son and I think
right now he's out there saying I'm
worried this guy might be assassinated
and I also think what's going on is um
we've had some very light news cycles
and so you pull this up and his dad
makes some comment like that and I think
you know
yeah do I think there's a real risk
there perhaps do I think his dad's
worried about it because he sees his son
really being a lightning rod here
absolutely I think his dad I think his
dad believes hey man you're touching
government you're touching you know very
heavy figures and you're demanding you
know this and that this uh you know I'm
a little worried that maybe somebody
might be upset enough about this to pop
him are you following the ADL story with
uh musk or no uh lightly I understand
you pull up that story with Forbes the
Anti-Defamation League oh my ad Revenue
has been manipulated because adl's been
out there pulling threads Tom let's not
forget the end of the day Pat Uh Elon
Musk spent how much money to buy X
Twitter 40 billion 40 billion dollars to
be like the Free Speech King because I
think it was 42 remember at the end of
the day Pat because of him and this
wasn't by the way obviously the FBI why
everybody was involved in embedded
inside of Twitter especially during the
election he's given us the opportunity
now on Twitter that we can see and hear
everything okay we see it we can fact
check it out we do what we just did and
we debate and everybody can have their
opinion but it's all out there the truth
though the fact that we can find out the
truth for ourselves makes him an enemy
of the elite he is giving us the
platform to do exactly what the hell we
did Pat and from from watching the
people on the ground in Maui talk about
what's really happening I'm saying to
listening to Larry Sinclair credible or
not whatever you want to say to the
January 6 Twitter files where it was the
January 6th guided tour it was an
Insurrection all the that they lied
to us about we get to see it in Pat I'm
telling you right now if there was a
list of accidental let's get this guy
Elon would be on top of that list right
now because he's giving us the
opportunity to see all the fiction about
covet to see all this and like just
let's put it on the table let us look at
it and figure it out before that would
you have ever have known all the
about Twitter or Hunter Biden or the
Latin none of that none of that time
because the White House the FBI were
going to Twitter and they were putting
agents there to say don't put the story
out do this do that do that so I will
100 think that he's on that list no the
modern government does not want an open
platform so musk blames Anti-Defamation
League for X's poor ad sales threatens
lawsuit go a little lower elamas it's a
U.S ad revenue for X formerly known as
Twitter was down 60 in a series of
tweets Monday and blamed it on critical
statements from the anti-defamational
league going so far as to threaten a
lawsuit against the group go lower musk
said the uh advertisers have told the
company they're receiving pressure from
ADL or Jewish non-governmental
organization that seeks to fight
anti-Semitism and extremism around the
world to not advertise on X he went to
say if this continues we will have no
choice but to follow defamation suit
against ironically the anti-defamational
League this comes after a deal released
multiple reports saying
anti-semitic reports uh posts have
spiked on X since musk's purchased the
platform unblocked the number of users
who had previously been kicked off the
site for violating hate speech and
loosened the platform's consent content
moderation policy I mean you can't blame
the guy for being upset about it this is
canceling by any other word if you can't
control can't get them to be quiet you
try to cancel them and if the ADL
doesn't like what certain people are
saying whether those people are truly
extremists and truly saying things uh
you know against Jewish people which I
hate to see but there there's a hyper
reaction here and they can't control X
so they want to influence others who can
cause control through cancellation and
boycotts yeah I don't believe in any
sort of cancellation even though I'm
Jewish you know I believe in free speech
I'm a free speech
absolutist to an extent
um I actually believe you should shine a
light on the people that are saying
racist anti-semitic bigoted comments
let's see who they are let's see I want
to see a picture of their face I
actually want to know where they live
let's see where they work highlight the
hell out of these guys
let's see what's going on let's dox the
hell out of these guys so yeah I totally
understand why someone like Elon would
want to push back against the ADL a lot
of people do uh but this is literally
their job is to go after people they
feel like are defaming minorities or uh
certain types of people
um but back to the Elon thing
him and his father have had a very
strand relationship over the years
um so I actually don't know how much
communication they even have so you said
it's maybe a light Newsweek so they're
just looking for anything uh to kind of
drum up but um pure speculation and I'm
sure elon's got it covered actually the
most famous text that Elon and his
father had this was a year ago was when
he texts his dad
um just keep quiet the Press is playing
you like a fiddle
um don't say anything anymore keep quiet
so he's basically saying dad
pump the brakes guy yeah so it didn't
like didn't seem like his father
listened to us let's go to this next
story The Immortals meet the
billionaires forking out for eternal
life and this is a guardian story so
let's see what Guardian has to say about
this Tech entrepreneur Brian Johnson who
spent hundreds of thousands of dollars
on youthful plasma transfusions shares
his experience I've never paid more
attention to what he's eating
uh because that was going into my I've
never paid more attention to what I'm
eating because I was going into my body
he continues to invest two million
dollars annually in longevity research
Professor Michael and Irina Conboy
discussed their groundbreaking research
in which they stitched together the
bodies of old and young mice to
rejuvenate the older mice's blood they
anticipate significant advancement in
prolonging life treatments such as pills
and a fountain of middle age in the next
five years the podcast explores the
involvement of billionaires like Jeff
Bezos and Peter Thiel and Longevity
research and raises moral concerns about
the potential exclusion of certain
groups interesting Vinnie so well first
of all let's listen I I don't care
anybody says you're not going to cheat
death we all have something in common
male female tall straight gay we all
have an expiration date this guy though
Pat is 45 years old he sold his company
pick Tech uh 800 million dollars he
recruited his 17 year old son and his 70
year old dad to join him in a
tri-generational blood exchange right in
April they visited Resurgence wellness
it's a futuristic Medical spinality in
Texas the sun got a leader of his blood
removed about fifth of his body a fifth
of the blood of his body and separated
into Parts before the plasma was
reinfused into his father all right now
Brian got the guy in question then
donated a leader of his blood products
to a 70 year old father and nobody don't
uh gave blood back to the son so the sun
is a out of luck so the sun's
basically Tom Hardy in uh Mad Max when
he's the blood bank he's just sitting
there and they got the blood blood yeah
blood bank so uh like he has 30
nutritionists MRI Specialists uh he
gives blood stool samples of all of his
or all day they're monitoring this guy
he even does penis you might want to
look into this guys just pay attention
penis Rejuvenation so he's erect for
three and a half hours a night Jesus Tom
I know he beat your record uh he does
Tom he does shock wave therapy three
times times a week in the hopes of
gaining teenage like
erections he even monitors and keeps
track like he has a journal he's like oh
I got a hard on and he writes it but
like Pat at this point you're trying to
cheat death it's like live your life the
way you are unless Adam you feel me
about like in the future take care of
yourself for right now but 30 people
around the clock working to make you
young listen I think it's safe to say if
you're drawing blood out of your son and
taking some of your dad's platelets
shoving in you giving somebody to Dad
it's it's going overboard you got to
chill out would you happen to have his
phone number
is Bill back in the studio but yeah what
do you think I think once it's once it's
your time bro it's like yeah we have to
go away so the Next Generation has a
chance he'll just be here forever but
stitching your body to somebody else's
is just a little time would you want to
live forever I think we've talked about
this would you want to live forever you
know I
I've seen really really elderly
um relatives go go quietly and I've I
had a 93 year old grandmother my uh
my mom's dad as the grandparent I was
closest to and when it was time for him
to go he was he was not ready to tap out
but he was so peaceful and as he had
aged he had things that were catching up
with him he didn't have cancer didn't go
through some long thing but he was 93
years old and he was really the body was
really worn out he worked as a machinist
so he had you know arthritis and his
wrists and his hands and everything and
he's like you know what I've seen a lot
of family grow up I've seen a lot of
things and you know I'm I'm ready for
the I'm ready for the step step to the
white tunnel and go meet God and I look
at it like that and I'm like I I say you
know do I want to be as healthy as I can
be and as productive as I can as long as
possible yes I don't know if I have any
desire to live 200 years
but I want to be as as healthy as it
will be an ideal age like if God's
listening right now watching this
podcast he's probably not watching
today's podcast because he's pissed but
if if he's watching today's podcast what
age would you want to live to I I think
I've I know my body and I know my status
and I think I'm good for 105. oh
dog what are you doing so you've got 20
more years you know my mom yeah I know I
I actually agrees well I actually agree
105. I think 200 is a great number to
Aspire to be yeah but I don't want to
look like a white walker from Game of
Thrones like I've seen some people where
it's like bro you no no no no you're
gonna be all right you don't have to
worry about your looks bro you're a good
looking guy but I mean pain but Pat my
back bro we got the freaking water at
lunch you're gonna get in it every day
at 89 years old would you live for would
you want to live forever hell no
I can't even imagine the the Pains of
like no no way Adam you no way I I want
to go to 100 I tell my mom my grandma's
92 I said I need you to 100 Grandma I
need to take care of yourself my mom is
70. I want her taking care of herself I
think you got this one life I think you
need to make the most of it and what I
will say this about this Hunter will be
cool this billionaire whatever he is
yeah Ryan Jones I would much rather
biohack Life Health Is wealth and spend
hundreds of thousand dollars on this and
then get your third Rolls Royce or your
second house somewhere it's like at this
point that's probably the best
investment you can make rather than some
material items and by the way you have
to know at that point that's exactly
what they're doing they don't get once
you have money like no one gives a
what you drive when you have money right
when you when you actually have real
money and I'm not talking like you know
I'm talking these guys are billionaires
it's called you like like when you
when you're pulling up to a guy that's
got a massive house you're not like so
what do you drive
I haven't driven in five years I have
this one friend that's worth a ton of
money he's he's gone on the record
basically saying that you know 150
million ain't what it used to be but
this guy is biohacking life and doing
ice baths for funds yeah and he's fired
up allegedly yeah
what a freaking nuts do you want to see
the first reaction when I got in the
water because I don't want to give it to
Rob it's going to take us a minute to do
it but man this experience today was
insane when I did this I can't wait to
go back and do it again tonight it's so
weird it's like a new toy I got uh
whether you get that than another car or
another one you think I want a like the
the reason why I love what I drive right
now is because I can sit in it we went
to lunch yesterday amazing Benny's in
the car he's in a car I'm gonna call him
comfortable the other stuff that the red
car I have that I just I can't I can't
fit it's not gonna work out so I'm with
you so okay all right so let's go to uh
which one do we want to go to what about
the Cowboys you want to go to Proud boys
former proud boys leader
sent sentenced to 22 years in prison a
Wall Street Journal story oh Wall Street
Journal story uh let's go through this
here former proud boys leader Enrique is
a 22-year sentence the longest in over a
thousand cases related to January 6 20
21 Capital assault after being convicted
of
sadacious conspiracy a charge related to
efforts to use Force to overthrow to
government impede its law or seize its
property prosecutors initially sought a
33-year sentence for Taria but
Saturday's leadership role and the proud
boys involved in the attack when
recommending through punishment or while
the U.S District Court Judge Timothy
Kelly
Express discomfort likening the events
to terrorism tario who did not enter the
capital himself apologized for his role
in instigating the events while his
defense team argued for a 15-year
sentence saying my client is no
terrorist my client is misguided Patriot
wait he never went in he's getting 20
that's the key he never even went inside
there so it's getting further and
further from the supposed
insurrectionists the rioters the
terrorists he wasn't in there uh he's
he's not a white supremacist Joe Biden
is quick to call proud boys a white
supremacy group his name is Enrique
he's a he's a afro-hispanic gentleman
and he's going to lose his whole 40s
he's going to be in prison from 39 to 51
if he gets out early what do you think
the sentence should be uh well let's
look at this does he have a prior record
has he done anything wrong in the past
because um you know the whole thing with
Biden is we got to give people second
third and fourth chance if it's someone
on the left but if it's someone on the
right oh give him life he wasn't even
there so
[Music]
first of all I I did because I'm gonna
be honest I didn't dive in and find out
all because I mean the guy was at his
house I don't know he planned
orchestrated my question is do you guys
remember that that group Pat you guys
might have remembered
um antifa during the entire during the
entire Trump presidency during the
George foreign fights these these people
who are peaceful protesters protested
funded by George Patton they caused
absolute Mayhem in this country they
cause violence they killed people they
burn down cities they did all this
and guess what when they got arrested
guess who bailed them out Hollywood
Elites uh Kamala Harris everybody's like
hey we got to help these people yeah
everybody yeah then they help them out
so however soon they got out that's how
quickly Enrique yeah exactly and guess
what on this January 6th this
Insurrection quotation marks that nobody
died nobody brought their guns nobody
nobody go to Liberty Safe to get their
guns exactly but here's is my thing
there I I think Adam I think a fair
thing would be you know if he did really
really incite violence like the ray Epps
the guy the the FBI that were like
everybody go in those people should be
in prison that he takes all those guys
so answer the question then how long
should he go to jail for I I said a
trick questions
all the specifics of what what evidence
do they have three months okay because
uh let me just you read the article it's
in front of your face yeah they were
they were trying number one I don't
really give a about this guy we
actually had the opportunity to bring
him on the podcast we said no
2021 yeah Pat's credit he's like nah you
know uh we don't go down that that far
right Rabbit Hole uh proud boy thing but
I will say this the prosecutors sought a
33-year sentence but what did his
defense want what did his defense ask
for a bargaining chip for how much how
many years 15 years 15 years so his
defense his defense attorney said to
very least give him 15 years they
settled they split the difference in 22
years so I'm just looking at it was
defense is basically saying basically
his defense is basically saying you're
going to jail buddy yeah and it's going
to happen for a while so this whole
thing by the way by the way good point
okay that even his defense is saying 15
years not saying nothing but also good
point on you if he's gotta go apps has
got to go absolutely they both go on the
same cell for 15 years now you're gonna
say fair but oh Epps gets off why he's
saying get into gun get into get into
Capital get into capital and there's
videos
epson's got to be inmates I agree
roommates with this guy we can sit there
and say you're being reasonable I will
say this guy rayap should be charged
with something but what he has not
charged should not be charged with is
this seditious conspiracy but this is my
speculation I haven't read into this all
that much but I know what it's the
distance conspiracy is he'd even go in
the capital it's kind of like he was the
party promoter he promoted the party
yeah it's called he sent out Liars he's
advertised the hell out of it that's but
he just didn't go to the pattern that's
called inciting a riot that's called and
that's called inciting an Insurrection
he's telling all these young he's
pushing the gates and pushing them to go
in he deserves to in fact I'm not
talking about ABS I'm talking about why
Enrique tari was going to jail he was
the big party promoter of the of the and
I'm not even on your okay I'm on your
page yeah I don't think it was an
Insurrection I I think it was a
rebellion yeah I think it was a
show I'm not on the Insurrection label I
get that people are calling you think
Ray I don't think these proud boys were
actually going to take over the
government I agree I actually think a
lot of them actually do love America
yeah have you guys met any of The Proud
boys have you ever had a interaction
with them I did a comedy show in North
Hollywood California guys with a bunch
of polo shirts after the show hey you're
funny I go what's going on with the
polos like oh you don't know where the
prod boys I go what do you guys do yeah
well antifa's been beating up old ladies
and Christians walking to the uh the
Trump rallies so we're show showing up
now and we're kind of giving them the
business if they mess with us I said
that sounds almost Noble like kind of
like a counter force and uh they say you
want to join I said no thanks and by the
way most of these we're gonna go first
let's go hang out yeah I'd be with uh
but um they were all by the way black
guys so not even a white wait so wait
they're white supremacist black guys
that doesn't make sense I know it didn't
make sense bro what were you about to
say something
what Kayvon said my mom was not on the
camera but she was in oh she was in
Washington DC soccer alert yes yes she
wasn't on the capitol but the proud boys
were providing security to the older
ladies my mom's in her 70s they were
guiding her around the city like badass
Boy Scouts and when a little guy jumps
out of the bushes with tight black pants
and throws an egg they would just go put
them in the hospital yeah there's groups
called the guardian angels with red
shirts that go back like in the 80s yes
yeah with all this and um you know I
look at it this way I'm not in the
courtroom here but if these if he gets
22 years then the three people that
organize the Kavanaugh Riot and protest
don't they get two some you know do you
remember this the Justice Kavanaugh Riot
they did the same thing broke through
the doors came inside pushed the cops
around and then it's I'm looking at it
saying what is the difference here why
don't those people get two years for
inciting a riot and breaking through the
doors and trying to make this protest
and then these guys get 22 years yeah I
just um I I'm still troubled by The
Selective prosecution here I will say
this that one of the things you have to
love about America is your ability to
protest or even Riot 164 people arrested
during the protest for crowding
obstructing or
they broke doors they came in there they
had looked tell me what the difference
is tell me what the difference is when
these guys broke through the Kavanaugh
they came around you know you know why
because they're registered Democrat
that's why and they're I'm saying okay
22 years
are you saying that this is comparable
to January they stopped the hearing of
no they came in I want to see what he's
talking about this is comparable to
January 6th this in a way once it breaks
free here I'm saying I want to see it
I'm saying well this guy gets 22 why do
these people not get two
it's a fair question okay it's a fair
question uh on on what Tom is saying so
let's do one last story and then we'll
wrap up the US government is investing
22 million dollars into developing
surveillance clothing that includes
shirts pants and underwear
uh that can record video and audio the
US government has invented 20 million
dollars smart electricity powered and
networked textile systems
called smart e-pens program aiming to
create weapon wearable clothing capable
of recording audio video and geolocation
data the program's goal is to produce
washable garments including shirts pants
socks and underwear with Advanced
surveillance capabilities the office of
the director of intelligence states that
is smartypants represents significant
investment and develop an active smart
textiles Dr Dawson kagold the program
manager for smart e-pans highlighted the
potential benefits for government
agencies like the Department of Defense
Department of Homeland Security and
intelligence Community he notes that
wearable Technologies could enhance
situational awareness by allowing users
to keep their hands free in high stress
environment Dr Kegel Dr Kegel that's
hilarious is that how you turn it on you
do it quick
can you imagine that like like that's
going to be the future
I have to tell you a secret like I can't
my underwear are listening yeah it's
like well think about it they're trying
to make Pat this is uh Brandon made this
a good point on my show yesterday the
Vincent ochana show Wednesdays
yeah the brand they're making
surveillance cool they're making it
stylish just like with Facebook you
remember during the Obama they were like
Obama's or it's our privacy and
everybody's fighting we don't want them
to know about I don't know where I
don't want you to follow me or all of a
sudden Facebook comes out and you're
willingly telling them where you eat who
you hang out with what your style is
what concerts you watch like the CIA
must worship Mark Zuckerberg because
they made it what cool difference a
decade makes exactly Tom now it's cool
this is my privacy I can't believe
you're doing this and then it's like
okay now it's like you're not on
Facebook number one let's go Brandon
congrats for you John Brandon number two
where was this technology when Larry
Sinclair was smoking crack with Obamas
no photos I'm sorry sorry as Obama was
sculpting down Larry Adam God oh never
mind if he had those pants technology
I'll say let's go Kayvon really great to
have you thank you congratulations bro
you gotta have two more vaults though
yeah we're not playing games
congratulations on uh being on the
podcast and congratulations on being the
newspaper the proud boys that's great
yeah
gang uh I hope you uh uh have a great
weekend we are about to announce four of
our next lives wow you get to pick and
choose which one you want to go it's
going to be a lot of different kind of
lives text award podcast to
310-340-1132 text award podcast to
310-340-1132 to be one the first to buy
the ticket so you're here with us live
at our Cigar Lounge and Comedy Club have
a great weekend everybody bye-bye
let's go